zdf heute live herzlich willkommen drei
tage noch bis zur wahl
zeit für die grosse schlussrunde hier im
zdf wir sind gleich live dabei wenn in
berlin die kandidierenden für das
bundeskanzleramt und die vorsitzenden
der anderen im bundestag vertretenen
parteien zum letzten mal die chance
haben vor einem millionen-publikum die
wählerinnen und wähler von sich zu
überzeugen was wir hier sehen sind noch
licht du willst die kandidatinnen und
kandidaten
kann man hier noch nicht sehen die
sammeln sich gerade und um viertel nach
acht geht es los und dann sind wir
natürlich live dabei die vorbereitungen
laufen also und wir freuen uns dass sie
und ihr mit dabei sind und seit wir
freuen uns über fragen wie immer in die
kommentare oder wenn ihr uns die die
zdf- heute- app nutzt bitte an die
eingeblendete und bekannte e mail
adresse da es sie
selten war eine wahl so spannend und
deshalb freue ich mich sehr darüber
heute abend so kurz vorher über den
entsprechen zu können mit professor
thorsten faas
politikwissenschaftler an der fau berlin
ich hoffe wir können ihn gleich sehen da
ist er herr fas grüße sie und jan
schepmann kollege von funk verantwortet
und moderiert dort das politik format
die da oben schön dass sie beide mit
dabei sind wir haben jetzt gute zehn
minuten geht's los geht und danach noch
ein bisschen mehr zeit um alles
miteinander einzuordnen
sie begleiten diesen wahlkampf schon
lange jetzt sind wir auf den letzten
metern was erwarten sie von heute abend
na ja ist schon nochmal ein wichtiges
ereignis weil man einfach die
wichtigsten personen auch die
wichtigsten themen noch mal im direkten
vergleich sehen kann wir wissen dass
viele noch unentschlossen sind und wir
wissen auch dass viele zwischen
verschiedenen parteien schwanken
insofern ist es eine schöne gelegenheit
diese vergleichsfunktion heute abend zu
erfüllen hängt ein bisschen davon ab wie
viele leute tatsächlich am ende
einschalten das waren bei den tri allen
sehr sehr viele motorrad ein bisschen
weniger sein aber trotzdem was ist noch
mal ein endspurt
einen aufschlag wirklich in die absolut
heiße phase und sie haben es gesagt dass
es immer noch einiges zu holen es ist
und bleibt spannend
wir sind per du deshalb fällt es mir
schwer dich jetzt in der sendung zu
sitzen ich hoffe die zuschauer himmel
inzwischen auf was sagen wir dass jan
von wem und an welcher stelle würdest du
dich heute abend gerne überraschen
lassen
ich glaube am ehesten von janine wissler
ich bin gespannt darauf wie sehr die
linke kompromissbereit sein wird dietmar
bartsch als fraktionsvorsitzender und
einer der spitzenkandidaten hat ja schon
so ein paar signale gegeben
inwiefern gewisse rote linien
möglicherweise bei möglichen
koalitionsgesprächen aufgeweicht werden
könnten
so wißler hat sich da in der
vergangenheit auch als ich mit ihr
gesprochen habe für die funk
kreuzverhöre noch nicht so
kompromissbereit gezeigt ich bin sehr
gespannt ob da vielleicht das ein oder
andere signal gesendet wird für eine
mögliche rot grün rote koalition option
ja da sind viele möglichkeiten offen
viele sagen ja dass die wahl erst nach
der wahl entschieden wird weil dann erst
abzusehen es werden mit wem koalieren
kann und will und wir blicken gleich mal
auf das was möglich ist christian volk
hat die verschiedenen optionen
zusammengetragen
ampel rot grün rot oder vielleicht doch
jamaika klar ist nach der bundestagswahl
könnten viele farbkombinationen an die
macht führen wahrscheinlich aus drei
parteien besonders gefragt ist in diesen
tagen die fdp die liberalen könnten zum
königsmacher werden entweder für armin
laschet in einem jamaika-bündnis oder
für olaf scholz in einer ampelkoalition
die fdp will sich noch nicht festlegen
aber
wir haben eine präferenz für jamaika
selbstverständlich gar keine frage wir
haben ein sehr gutes
vertrauensverhältnis steht nordrhein
westfalen wie ihr selbst mit den grünen
gemeinsam in schleswig holstein und der
union auch die linken scheinen wieder im
rennen zu sein nach den jetzigen zahlen
könnte es für rot grün rot reichen es
gibt viele gemeinsamkeiten im
parteiprogramm aber spd kandidat scholz
will von den linken ein bekenntnis zur
nato das gibt es bisher nicht das hilft
nicht viel voneinander bekenntnisse zu
verlangen wir haben ja gerade gesehen
das scheitern der nato in afghanistan
und ich bin eigentlich der meinung dass
jetzt mal die parteien die die
bundeswehr dorthin geschickt haben in
diesen auslandseinsatz noch einmal
reflektieren sollten ob das eine
richtige entscheidung war wir sind der
meinung dass es nicht so war außerdem
möglich eine deutschland koalition aus
spd union und fdp oder ein kenia bündnis
spd union und grüne die farbspiele
laufen in berlin auf hochtouren nur mit
der afd möchte niemand koalieren
der unterfahrt man hat das gefühl eine
große koalition für dieses jahr
rechnerisch nach den zahlen auch
erreichen würde stand jetzt die möchte
auch keiner mehr erhalten sie das für
ausgeschlossen
denn überhaupt nicht und alleine die
tatsache dass diese groko eine mehrheit
hätte habt ihr auch implikationen etwa
für ein sogenanntes kenia bündnis oder
ein sogenanntes deutschland bündnis weil
wir dann von bündnissen reden in denen
die grünen bzw die fdp eigentlich
rechnerisch nicht gebraucht würden das
wäre auch ein novum dass beim parteien
quasi in eine koalition aufnimmt die es
eigentlich nicht braucht für eine
mehrheit all das zeigt das ist ein sehr
zähes thema da tun sich bin gespannt wie
es heute abend ein wird aber da tun sich
auch die politikern politiker schwer
klar farbe zu bekennen strategisch wäre
das auch nicht klug jetzt sich sozusagen
die spielräume einzuengen aber trotzdem
wollen wir als wählerinnen und wähler
natürlich wissen was kommt denn da auf
uns zu und wir wissen auch dass ist
nicht egal ob wir von einem rot rot
grünen bündnis oder eine jamaika bündnis
regiert werden das hat folgen für das
was im land passiert so fern ist es
tatsächlich mal so ein punkt wir würden
sehr gerne wissen aber es wäre glaube
ich ihm so risch zu glauben dass wir
heute abend da definitiver antworten
bekommen das macht ja fast ein bisschen
langweilig ja weil man nicht damit
rechnen kann dass heute abend an
irgendeiner stelle so richtig tief drin
sein wird weil zumindest die die
optionen auf die macht haben sie es mit
keinem verscherzen wollen oder glaubst
du schon dass da heute der eine oder
andere irgendwie nochmal einen vorlegt
vielleicht gar nicht aus dem kreis der
drei kanzler kandidatinnen sondern aus
den anderen parteien
ich glaube eine erster linie kämpft
erstmal jeder für sich selber und so
knapp wie das gerade aktuell ist wäre
das glaube ich auch nicht sehr klug es
anders zu machen
ich glaube dass armin laschet jetzt auf
den letzten metern noch mal wirklich gas
geben muss und noch mal wirklich alle
register ziehen muss um noch mal
irgendwie 1 2
prozentpunkte in den umfragen noch mal
vielleicht zu schaffen und ansonsten
glaube ich schon dass es kein kein
freundlicher applaus werden wird ich bin
sehr auf markus söder gespannt ob er
sich so als die mit der rolle als als
zweiter im glied jetzt gerade anfreunden
kann oder ob er jetzt zeigen möchte was
man hätte haben können hätte man ihn
gewählt das ist so ein bisschen wie die
die die wild card heute abend
beziehungsweise die große unbekannte
aber ich glaube schon dass da ganz gut
dampf drauf sein könnte doch jetzt auf
die letzten meter ja das ist ja in der
tat eine ganz interessante konstellation
söder und laschet böse angeschrieben das
ist zum ersten mal dass söder und
laschet live direkt gegeneinander
antreten
erfasst das ist echt ne schwierige kiste
für beide
was erwarten sie da
das ist interessanterweise die
erwartungen die man hat wenn man die
vorgeschichte im kopf habe zugleich ist
es natürlich eine riesenchance
theoretisch dass man hier armin laschet
einerseits die chance bietet sich als
der große kanzler zukünftige kanzler zu
präsentieren während markus söder
gleiche partei wenn man so will
schwesterparteien markus söder er die
rolle des angreifers derjenige der dann
vielleicht die anderen auch mal härter
an geht heute abend einnehmen könnte
also das hat strategisch durchaus charme
für die union wie sie sich da heute
abend präsentiert ob es vom typ her
gerade bei söder wirklich möglich sein
wird bin ich auch sehr sehr gespannt hat
söder hat heute in einem interview
gesagt die tat ich bin wohl der
freundlichste csu-vorsitzende den hier
ein cdu-vorsitzende erleben durfte
denken sie nur an horst seehofer und
angela merkel oder franz josef strauß
und helmut kohl nicht mal die spd hat
olaf scholz so gefeiert auf ihrem
parteitag wie die csu armin laschet ist
das ein bisschen eine versteckte drohung
ja man darf nicht vergessen dass die csu
in bayern jetzt gerade auch nicht
sonderlich gut dasteht und
so zynisch ist sich von vom eigenen
kanzlerkandidaten abzugrenzen der ja
auch nicht gerade gute beliebtheitswerte
hat kann auch mittel seien zumindest
seine eigenen hintern in bayern zu
retten und ich glaube dass kein einziger
csu kandidatin bayern auf ein mögliches
direktmandat verzichten möchte von daher
wie man markus söder kennt der freistaat
bayern kommt bei ihm ein jemand zuerst
und das ist tatsächlich die unbekannte
heute
herr fast es gibt eine frage von georgi
17 über youtube der sagt die deutschen
gehen zu sehr nach den kandidaten und zu
wenig nach partei und programm
wir haben natürlich auch gerade mit dem
fokus auf armin laschet erlebt dass er
durch seine schlechten geschlecht als
schlecht wahrgenommene performance die
umfragewerte mit nach unten gezogen hat
in den letzten wochen während die spd
mit den beliebtheitswerten von olaf
scholz er im aufwind war was sagen sie
zu dem kann kommentar weniger auf die
kandidaten gucken und er auf die
parteien und als aufs programm
er ist das immer so ein bisschen viel
entweder oder weil letztlich ist es
natürlich und das werden wir auch heute
abend erleben ein paket dass ich da als
wählerin als wähler mir in
anführungszeichen einkaufe wir haben
sicherlich sehr sehr viel über personen
gesprochen das ist richtig und an vielen
stellen auch war sehr sehr viele details
von lebensläufen fußnoten etc gesprochen
aber man darf nicht vergessen es geht
auch darum und das zum ersten mal im
nachfolge merkel zu suchen es geht also
wirklich darum wem vertrauen wir das
mächtigste amt was wir in diesem land
haben an und da finde ich schon legitim
dass man dann auch die kandidierenden
doch einem einem test wenn man so will
im wahlkampf unterzieht denn es wäre
eine illusion zu glauben dass wir in
diesem wahlkampf erschöpfend alle themen
werden diskutieren und behandeln können
die in den nächsten vier jahren auf der
politischen agenda erscheinen man muss
ja nur mal zurück gucken corona konnte
2010 kein thema sein
flüchtlingssituation 2015 konnte im
wahlkampf 2013 kein thema wir versuchen
an dieser stelle einen fliesen break mit
dem versprechen nach der sendung genau
da wieder einzusetzen und jetzt geben
wir ab nach berlin
denn gleich beginnt die schlussrunde in
ard und zdf moderiert von tina hassel
und theo koll und wir sind gespannt wie
das ausgehen wird bis später
mit dabei wenn ich die zeit noch nutzen
darf sind annalena baerbock firmen den
grünen und jetzt sehe ich dass es
losgeht armin laschet olaf scholz die
kanzlerkandidatin und die kandidaten und
die vorsitzenden der im bundestag
vertretenen parteien los
noch bis zu dieser ganz besonderen
bundestagswahl und noch immer wissen
viele nicht was oder wen sie wählen
werden deshalb wollen tina hassel und
ich in dieser runde einige der wichtigen
themen ausloten die bisher wenig oder
gar nicht behandelt wurden neben corona
und dem zustand unserer gesellschaft
geht es auch um deutschlands künftige
rolle in der welt ja denn ganz gleich
wer diese wahl
hinterher gewinnen wird sie wird eine
zeitenwende sein und deshalb haben sie
in den kommenden 90 minuten die
möglichkeit noch einmal alle argumente
aller parteichefs spitzen kandidaten und
kandidatinnen sehr genau zu prüfen und
natürlich auch zu beobachten wie die
runde miteinander umgeht wo eventueller
wursten gemacht werden oder ganz klare
grenzen gesetzt werden auf jeden fall
herzlich willkommen zur schlussrunde in
ard und zdf und hier sind unsere gäste
in strengt alphabetischer reihenfolge
guten haben sondern der burg
spitzenkandidatin kanzlerkandidatin der
grün willkommen armin laschet
kanzlerkandidat der union
und willkommen christian lindner hat
spitzenkandidat der fdp und wir begrüßen
natürlich auch olaf scholz den
kanzlerkandidaten der spd wir begrüßen
den csu chef markus söder die
spitzenkandidaten der afg alice weisel
und für die linke deren
spitzenkandidatin janine wissler und wir
beginnen mit einem aktuellen thema das
im moment die republik erschüttert und
viele fassungslos macht einen masken
verweigerer erschießt einen jungen
passiere in einer tankstelle weil der
ihn auf die krone regeln hingewiesen
hatte im netz wird der täter von vielen
dafür sogar zynisch gefeiert die
polizeigewerkschaft gdp spricht schon
davon dass sich die szene der korona
leugner immer weiter radikalisiert herr
laschet experten haben ja schon lange
gewarnt dass es nur noch eine frage der
zeit ist wann aus hasserfüllten
botschaften irgendwann auch eine tat
folgt haben sie haben wir alle diese
szene zu lange unterschätzt
also der anschlag in idar oberstein ist
natürlich schrecklich man kann sich das
kaum vorstellen ein 20 jähriger jobbt da
student tut nichts anderes als auch die
regeln hinzuweisen und dann wird der
kaltblütig erschossen und meine sorge
bei all diesen taten ist die
radikalisierung beginnt im netz immer
aggressiver immer lauter wir haben es
bei den rechtsradikalen erlebt werden
stimmungsmache gegen walter lübke und
irgendwann ist einer da unvollendet
diese tat und das müssen wir dringend
diesem hass uns entgegenstellen und ihn
schon im ansatz ersticken
aber herr laschet die unionsfraktion hat
wichtige vorhaben verhindert das
sogenannte wehrhafte demokratie gesetzt
auch ein gesetz zur besseren überprüfung
von waffenbesitzern das hat jetzt der
innenminister seehofer selber kritisiert
also dieser hass
lässt sich auch nicht durch eine
wehrhafte demokratie gesetzt beseitigen
wir brauchen eine wehrhafte demokratie
wir brauchen auch regeln wie man
rassismus fremdenfeindlichkeit
gewalt von allen seiten wie man die
bekämpft aber
die gesellschaftliche sorge die sich mit
diesem anschlag verbindet dass die
tonlage immer rauer wird und immer
aggressiver wird das ist etwas was wir
bekämpfen müssen und vor allem muss
jeder wissen der das macht er wird hier
auch auf die härte des rechtsstaats
treffen müssen wir dürfen es nicht
dulden
in nordrhein westfalen haben wir
beispielsweise die praxis dass wir nicht
nur löschen im netz sondern auch die die
verletzten direkt strafrechtlich
verfolgen und ich glaube das ist
erforderlich
auch das internet ist kein rechtsfreier
raum herr scholz die stichwort wehrhafte
demokratie
die spd zeigt sich ja beim thema
online-durchsuchung bisher zurückhaltend
bis gespalten ihre justiz ministerin
wollte sie die parteichefin hat das
ganze gestoppt wie würde sich ein
kanzler scholz entscheiden wir haben
hier eine ganze reihe von gesetzen auf
den weg gebracht und auch beschlossen
die genau das möglich machen dass man
überprüft was alles für aktivitäten
stattfinden dass man dass man abhören
kann wo es nicht am telefon ist dann
eben gleichzeitig im netz das sind die
maßnahmen die wir möglich gemacht haben
und ich glaube dass ich so und ich
glaube dass wir auf alle fälle auch im
netz den hass bekämpfen müssen und
deshalb müssen wir auch verfolgen können
was da stattfindet und was für
kommunikationswege da sind mit den neuen
gesetzen ist das möglich mit dem dass
wir als regierung auf den weg gebracht
haben das aber leider gescheitert
deswegen am streit über andere fragen
muss man ehrlicherweise sagen mit dem
bundesrat wäre das auch noch besser
möglich gewesen aber das sollten wir in
der nächsten legislaturperiode gleich
wieder versuchen das heißt sie sagen
selber es war nicht nur ausreichend nein
es sind ja mehrere gesetze für mehrere
sicherheitsbehörden für die meisten ist
es durchgekommen für die eine licht aber
das war etwas wo es ein streit gang und
bei andere fragen zwischen dem
innenminister den bundestagsfraktionen
und dem bundesrat ich selber hätte es
gut gefunden wenn das gesetz das die
bundesregierung auf den weg gebracht
auch was geworden wäre das will ich
gerne dazu sagen und will das nochmal
ergänzen wir brauchen klare maßnahmen im
netz um auch dort hasskriminalität
bekämpfen zu können wir brauchen eine
gute ausstattung von polizei und
sicherheitsbehörden damit wir alles
machen können um die täter zu
identifizieren und wir müssen auch im
gesellschaftlichen raum handeln können
deshalb finde ich wäre es gut gewesen
wenn das von der regierung entwickelte
wehrhafte demokratie gesetz auch im
bundestag beschlossen worden wäre ist ja
schon gesagt worden dass es nicht zu
stande gekommen ist weil die
unionsfraktion dann nicht mitmachen
wollte und ich finde es auch gut wenn
die idee die der innenminister die
innenminister der länder haben das wir
psychisch labile personen
überprüfen können und sagen können die
dürfen keine waffen besitzen wenn die
auf eine seite auf dass wir noch warten
aber herr lindner politiker in diesen
zeiten sind ja auch vorbilder wenn jetzt
der fdp bundestags vizepräsident kubicki
gerade gesagt hat er sei während des lok
downs in illegal geöffneter kneipen
gegangen und das sei auch sein recht
gewesen was ist das für ein signal die
fdp hat eine ganz klare haltung regeln
müssen beachtet werden wir haben fraglos
eine etwas andere abwägung als die
kolleginnen und kollegen bei der
verhältnismäßigkeit von freiheits
eingriffen haben uns oft eine andere
balance zwischen gesundheitsschutz und
auch der achtung von bürgerrechten
gewünscht aber das natürlich vollkommen
zu trennen von der radikalisierung die
wir gegenwärtig beobachten
die muss man entschieden zurückweisen
und im übrigen auch unseren staat
ertüchtigen schon vor einigen jahren hat
der damalige innenminister thomas de
maizière darauf hingewiesen dass unsere
sicherheitsarchitektur in deutschland
modernisierungsbedürftig ist
insbesondere bundesamt für den
verfassungsschutz und die 16 landesämter
für den verfassungsschutz müssen besser
und koordiniert zusammenarbeiten
diesen aufruf von herrn de maizière sind
leider keine taten gefolgt ich glaube
eine nächste bundesregierung muss unsere
sicherheitsarchitektur in deutschland
modernisieren und im übrigen auch die
digitalisierung oft genug ist das keine
frage von gesetzgebung sondern von
verwaltungs- zusammenarbeit aber ein
wort noch als parteichef zu herrn
kubicki und der äußerung also
signalwirkung in illegale kneipen
gegangen und das sei sein recht gewesen
ich habe mich für die fdp gerade
positioniert haben kubicki müssen sie
nach seinen persönlichen
jetzt nicht hier eben nach seinem
persönlichen hintergrund befragen wir
sind eindeutig und übrigens die regeln
in schleswig-holstein macht ein
fdp-gesundheitsminister frau wissen
dabei thema ertüchtigung der demokratie
die linke ist für die abschaffung des
verfassungsschutzes wer soll denn dann
nach ihrer meinung die radikalisierten
teile beispielsweise von corona leugnern
im netz kontrollieren oder im auge
behalten ja wir haben ja gesehen in der
ganzen geschichte das nsu dass der
verfassungsschutz er teilt das problem
war und nicht der lösung und ich hab
selber eines untersuchungsausschuss und
hessen im land hat mitgearbeitet habe
dort fünf jahre lang in die abgründe
dieser behörde gesehen und wir sind
wieder da hat die frage ja wir sind
insbesondere meinung dass wir das v
männer system beenden müssen weil gab
wir da werden ja neonazis dafür bezahlt
dass die neonazis sind und wir sind der
meinung dass geheimdienste in einer
demokratie einfach nicht parlamentarisch
zu kontrollieren sind deswegen brauchen
wir eine aufklärung stelle die anders
arbeitet als mit geheimdienstlichen
mitteln also nicht mit v männern die aus
der nazi szene angeworben werden die
gelder bekommen auf deren informationen
man sich nicht verlassen kann und da
sind wir der meinung sind einfach nicht
die richtigen lehren aus der geschichte
des senders gezogen worden weil die
parlamentarische kontrolle der
geheimdienste eher noch verschlechtert
wurde als verbessert und wir gesehen
haben dass es ein eigenleben gibt dass
geheimdienste entwickeln also unfalls
oder kern trios waren ja über 40 v
männer der verschiedenen
verfassungsschutzbehörden und die haben
es entweder nicht mitbekommen oder nicht
mitbekommen wollen darauf wies er sie
glauben also mit dem vorschlag das haben
sie erklärt würde es besser gehen man
kann da seine zweifel haben aber ich
würde gerne frau berg ins spiel holen
unter diesen radikalen querdenkern sind
ja viele die sich wirklich im widerstand
gegen eine selbst erfundene diktatur
wählen und deshalb auch glauben dass
selbst gewalt legitim wäre was ist denn
die antwort der grünen was ist ihr
konzept wie man mit diesen menschen
umgehen sollte schönen guten abend
erstmal wir brauchen einen dreiklang und
das bedeutet zuallererst dass wir
deutlich machen müssen natürlich sind
wir ein freies land das ist die stärke
unseres lands die meinungsfreiheit aber
da wo es in hass und hetze wo es im
bedrohung für andere umschlägt da gibt
sich nur widerspruch sondern da greift
der rechtsstaat voll und ganz zu und das
erste problem ist dass das im netz nicht
entsprechend stattfindet weil ganz viele
dieser aufrufe sind dann in messenger
gruppen in chat gruppen wo eben
entsprechend nicht umgesetzt werden kann
deswegen erste wichtige maßnahme gerade
auch mit blick auf die großen
plattformen löschung das hatten wir auch
in diesem wahlkampf immer wieder
deutlich zu sehen dass nicht schnell
gelöscht und straff ermittelt wird
zweiter punkt ist mit blick auf schnelle
verfahren auch das haben wir jetzt
gesehen plakate auf meine partei hängt
die grünen aber es hat auch uns alle
drei getroffen das sind im prinzip mord
aufrufe gewesen wo dann mit blick auf
den rechtsstaat eben gesagt wird naja ob
das jetzt wirklich ein aufruf ist das
bedeutet auch zweitens und das hat die
große koalition nicht umfassend
angegangen mit blick auf die gerichte wo
wir eine rechtsstaats offensive und vor
allen dingen mehr personal brauchen und
der dritte wichtige punkt und da sieht
man auch dass wir uns hier zwischen den
parteien unterscheiden bei diesem
furchtbaren
vorfall bei diesem furchtbaren attentat
jetzt aber auch vorher bei den
mordanschlägen auch bei amokläufen waren
immer wieder waffen im umlauf entweder
illegal oder auch waffen die legal
waffenschein hat nun dann trotzdem zu so
vielen morden geführt haben das heißt ja
wir brauchen dringend eine verschärfung
des waffenrechts in deutschland vor
weiter wir haben vom bundesinnenminister
gehört dass sich teile der querdenker
szene zunehmend radikalen die renerco
spitzenkandidat copala hat sogar zur
teilnahme an querdenker demos aufgerufen
wäre es in einem solchen moment nicht
höchste zeit sich von dieser szene klar
zu distanzieren
ich halte grundsätzlich nichts von
einer stigmatisierung einer
protestbewegung die sich im übrigen zu
großen teilen auch aus grünen spd cdu
wählern zusammensetzt das hat ja auch
eine erhebung ergeben
und dementsprechend sollten wir kritiker
von maßnahmen nicht stigmatisieren das
trägt nicht zur lösung der probleme
signalisierten nein also es gilt ja
grundsätzlich
gewaltfreiheit sie können ihre meinung
artikulieren sie können vom
demonstrationsrecht gebrauch machen das
ist ja auch in unserem grundgesetz
verankern nicht war aber natürlich
völliger gewaltfreiheit aber jetzt noch
mal zurück zu meinem punkt die
stigmatisierung von weiten teilen der
bevölkerung die korona maßnahmen auch
kritisieren und aus meiner sicht völlig
zu recht weil sie in weiten teilen
grundgesetzwidrig sind
das sollte man nicht tun und wenn wir
als politiker eben auch anfangen
geimpfte als versuchskaninchen zu
bezeichnen und ungeimpfte als sozial
schädlinge
soll haben wir ein gesellschaftliches
problem aber genau da fängt es an genau
da fängt die polarisierung in unserer
gesellschaft ran wenn die mal das dürfen
sie nicht machen weil wir politik geben
zum video call by call das ist die
verantwortung der politik die menschen
nicht zu stigmatisieren sie nicht als
sozial schädlinge zu
bezeichnen oder als versuchskaninchen da
fängt es doch an und der staat die
regierung sollten die
grundgesetzwidrigen maßnahmen
zurücknehmen
sie haben jetzt nichts zu herrn
tillschneider gesagt zum beispiel aber
und seinen corona diktatur äußerung aber
lassen was an der stelle sie haben ihren
punkt da gemacht und herr kolat design
gemacht herr söder sie befürworten ja im
team vorsicht die 2g regel sie haben
auch jetzt gemeinsam eben mit den
anderen parteien die quarantäne ohne
lohnfortzahlung
beschlossen spalten wir sehenden auges
mit diesen zunehmenden druck auf
ungeimpfte die gesellschaft also
friedrich merz zum beispiel er sagt da
wir müssen über die masken pflicht
nachdenken weil sie gesellschaftlich
spaltet das was ist ihre position da
gespalten nicht die gesellschaft für
beschützen sie wir haben jetzt drei
wellen sehr gut überstanden und es ist
einfach unwahr zu behaupten es handelt
sich um grundrechtswidrigen eingriff
nahezu alle maßnahmen sind von den
verfassungsgerichten der länder oder des
bundes verfassungs wird das ständig
überprüft worden und wurden mit 98%
entscheidungen immer wieder bestätigt
insofern ist diese ständige suggestion
die vermittelt wird er sei
grundgesetzwidrig einer der voba für die
grad afd gemacht wird muss denn die sie
stimuliert sie stigmatisiert nicht aber
sie stimuliert leute genau in diese
hinein zu kommen es geht ja nicht um die
ihnen die unsicher sind darüber muss man
reden man muss auch angebote machen bei
denen die unsicher sind beim impfen aber
ab einer bestimmten schwelle und es sind
die querdenker gibt es ein weltbild das
dahinter steht das in einer form erklärt
ist und zwar nicht quer denken er wird
nicht mehr gedacht da wird immer mehr
sich hinein verkrochen in eine situation
die dann am ende übrigens nicht nur mit
anti establishment argumenten versehen
wird sondern vor allen dingen auch mit
anti semitischen mit sehr vielen
rassistischen parolen ich habe das auch
bei unserem parteitag immer fröhlichen
was ich auch immer bekommen seit vielen
jahren jetzt ist es für alle die ihren
darum besitzen nicht so das problem wir
werden auch nicht geschützt aber es gibt
so viele viele menschen engagiert der
medizinerin mediziner pflegerinnen und
pfleger journalistin journalisten
kommunalpolitikerin kommunalpolitiker
die einen druck ausgesetzt sind und
immer wieder wenn die aufforderung kommt
distanziert euch von so etwas dann hören
wir so argumente wie gerade und die
einzige chance die es gibt heißt auf die
unsicheren zugehen und sie mitnehmen auf
diesen prozess aber auch ein klares
stopp schild machen denen gegenüber die
diesen staat bedrohen einschüchtern
sorry wenn ich das auch sage ohne
verfassungsschutz wird es da nicht gehen
denn diese leute verstehen jetzt nicht
mehr irgendwie ein eine nette ansprache
so am rande oder oder mal so eine ein
vertrauliches gespräch die erwarten sich
auch und sie müssen spüren dass der
staat mit ganze entschlossenheit handelt
und wenn ich das jetzt so höre die einen
wollen nicht stigmatisieren die anderen
wollen den verfassungsschutz abschaffen
da braucht es eine klare linie und klare
kante gegen überzeugend werde schauen
wir auf ein thema das nicht minder
wichtig ist für den sozialen
zusammenhalt das thema wohnen alle 20
minuten geht eine sozialwohnung verlor
jeden tag sind das 72 wohnungen die aus
der sozialbindung fallen die folge
bezahlbarer wohnraum nimmt dramatisch ab
laschet sozialwohnung waren doch
eigentlich ein deutsches erfolgskonzept
in den vergangenen 15 jahren hat sich
die zahl der sozialwohnungen aber fast
halbiert müssen wir da nicht eingestehen
wir haben versagt wir brauchen mehr
sozialwohnungen auf jeden fall wir haben
jetzt viele sozialwohnungen die aus der
mietpreisbindung herausfallen und
deshalb ist es erforderlich bis zum
jahre
2025 1 5 millionen wohnungen neu zu
bauen und da müssen auch viele
sozialwohnungen bei sein aber der kern
ist ja nicht vom himmel der kern ist man
muss bauen man kann nicht durch
technische mittel durch künstliche dinge
wie das hier in berlin gemacht worden
ist vom rot rot grünen senat glauben
dass man das problem löst wir müssen
bauen bauen bauen das wird die lage auf
dem wohnungsmarkt entspannen und neben
dem freien wohnungsmarkt brauchen wir
mehr sozialen wurden aber die frage was
die politik da nicht versagt ich meine
das ist eine erkenntnis die hätte man ja
haben können
also ich sehe dass die politik in den
letzten jahren vieles unternommen hat
das wir natürlich eine
zunehmende entwicklung haben dass viele
menschen in die großen städte sie ziehen
die städte sind zum magneten geworden
deshalb ist es aus meiner sicht auch so
wichtig das leben im ländlichen raum
auch attraktiv zu halten wenn jeder
denkt er muss in die große stadt ziehen
wo sein arbeitsplatz ist wird die
spaltung zwischen stadt und land noch
größer werden deshalb setzen wir uns
sehr dafür in den ländlichen raum zu
stärken die bedingungen dort auch so zu
machen dass man dort leben kann das
pendeln übrigens anzuerkennen mit einer
pendlerpauschale und vielem anderen was
ermöglicht dass menschen dort auch
weiter ihrer arbeit nachgehen können und
das andere ist die realität ist dass
immer mehr menschen in städten wohnen
deshalb müssen wir da gegensteuern frau
berben wohnungsnot in den großen städten
ist ein massives problem ich glaube da
sind bei uns alle am tisch einer meinung
die grüne spitzenkandidatin in berlin
bettina jarasch schließt enteignungen
von wohnungsunternehmen als ultima ratio
zumindest nicht aus wie sie das bei
ihnen aus
wir haben eine der zentralsten sozialen
fragen unserer zeit seit einem jahrzehnt
jetzt nicht gelöst und zwar seit einem
jahrzehnt nicht gelöst von der großen
koalition wir erleben nicht nur hier in
berlin sondern wir leben auch in münchen
in hamburg dass menschen in großen
deutschen städten nicht mehr in ihren
vierteln bleiben können dass sie
vertrieben werden dass familien das
krankenschwester rentnerinnen und
rentner im zweifel sogar sagen ich will
eine kleinere wohnung haben aber dies
seien doppelt so teuer nicht mehr da
sein können aber das ist armut leben
beschreibung ja wer selber um was zu
lösen muss man erst mal beschreiben und
ich frag mich echt auf wo die
sozialdemokratie war als man sie
eigentlich brauchte weil das die
sozialen bindung aufgelöst worden ist
das ist ja nichts was man nicht ändern
könnte sondern damit wohnraum nicht aus
der sozialen bindung will kann man das
gesetz ändern an der stelle man hätte
auch dafür sorgen können dass legen die
wahl tun weil ja gucken jetzt zurück was
man hätte tun das gegenteil wurde getan
dass für den sozialen wohnungsbau wurden
ein drittel 500.000 euro auch vom
finanzminister gekürzt den ländern
gegeben hieß es war aber eigentlich für
kosten der integration so und wenn wir
jetzt sagen das kann nicht so
weitergehen wo wir alle sagen wir sind
einer meinung dann muss man jetzt auch
deutlich machen dass wir für diese orte
und das ist der vorschlag in berlin auch
von unserer spitzenkandidatin für diese
orte wo die menschen vertrieben werden
aus ihren vierteln deutlich macht wir
kommen hier alle an einen tisch das ist
ihr vorschlag und sagen mit den
unterschiedlichen
wohnungsbaugenossenschaft mit den
eigentümern mit den lilien verwaltung
wir sorgen gemeinsam dafür dass die
mieten nicht um mehr als 2,5 prozent
erhöht werden im rahmen des mietpreises
spiegelt und wenn dann weiterhin nichts
passiert dann muss man auch dafür sorgen
was bedeutet das auch dass die menschen
ihrer stadt bleiben aber die haltung die
wir jetzt haben von der großen koalition
nichts zu tun und einfach weiter zu
bauen dann bauen wir im luxus-segment
und der mittelschicht und
geringverdienern hilft das dank einfach
nur ganz kurz und drei kommen als ultima
ratio finden sie unter den beschriebenen
umständen also richtig na das ist ja
keine erhaltungs frage sondern es steht
klar im grundgesetz was aufgabe von
staatlichkeit ist und es gelang ihm im
grund gerecht ein lebensmittel auch sie
jetzt auch starts richtung steht doch
nicht drin so nicht allein das mittel
dass ein letztes mittel auch am start
zur verfügung steht aber wir haben klar
gemacht als grüne in berlin und auch im
bund wir müssen alle schritte da
fortgehen dh die löcher in der mietpreis
bremse die müssen jetzt endlich
geschlossen werden das bedeutet endlich
die mittel für sozialen wohnungsbau
weiter zu erhöhen und das bedeutet in
den hot spots wo menschen nicht mehr
bleiben können dafür zu sorgen dass die
mieten nicht einfach willkürlich weiter
erhöht aber es war auf jeden fall ein
jahr zur enteignung wenn ich das richtig
verstanden brüssel jetzt haben wir sind
ja vorzugehen
extrem reden wenn man die schritte nach
vorne gegangen aber trotzdem haben sich
das letzte was laden imperial und es ist
klar ein eigenes modell front berlin das
vor dem verfassungsgericht scheitern
wird alle vorträge es ist eigentlich
nach erhaltung anders als bei ihnen
dinge zu lösen probleme zu lösen und
lege ich erst mal probleme zu
beschreiben und dann sagen wir machen
die pistole gehört das recht auf wohnen
in unsere verfassung bei darauf ein
recht was alle menschliche oder vista
ihr sie haben im grunde die antwort
schon gegeben und hier in berlin wird ja
am sonntag auch darüber abgestimmt große
wohnungsunternehmen zu enteignen sie
sind dafür aber diese teuren
enteignungen schaffen nicht eine einzige
neue wohnung ja sie verhindern dass
bezahlbarer wohnraum immer weiter
zerstört wird und das ist ja das problem
dass bezahlbarer wohnraum vernichtet
wird und ich verstehe die aufregung auf
der anderen seite gar nicht beim thema
enteignungen also ist eine schwarz-gelbe
landesregierung nordrhein westfalen
gewesen wie zum beispiel für den
kohleabbau überhaupt kein problem hatte
zu enteignen oder für autobahnprojekte
da enteignen sie doch auch und das
grundgesetz lässt das doch möglich also
lässt das noch zu dass im interesse des
gemeinwohls auch enteignungen
stattfinden und in berlin geht es
einfach um die frage das wäre eine
massive wohnungsnot haben und bauen
bauen bauen ist nicht die antwort weil
erstens wird in diesem jahr land ja jede
menge gebaut und jede menge bezahlt und
bezahlbarer wohnraum und wir können auch
nicht die letzte fläche versiegeln ist
auch umweltpolitisch nicht so klug wir
müssen verhindern dass immer mehr
wohnraum der bezahlbar war irgendwann
nicht mehr bezahlbar ist und all die
häuser und wohnungen die sich die
menschen in den innenstädten nicht mehr
leisten kann hier sind ja nicht auf
einmal weg durch wundersame art und
weise sondern die gibt es ja noch die
mieten gestiegen und deswegen sagen wir
enteignung ist eine sache da wird ja in
berlin am wochenende abgestimmt und das
ist ja nun volksentscheid das heißt die
menschen können ja demokratisch darüber
entscheiden und ich gehe davon aus dass
ich dann eine nächste regierung in
berlin daran auch hält aber ein anderes
wichtiges instrument der mieten decke
und den fordern wir als linke bundesweit
wir brauchen im mieten deckel und die
mieterinnen und mieter zu schützen damit
eben die geringverdiener aber auch die
normalverdiener nicht verdrängt werden
aus den innenstädten hier müssen wir
dringend etwas tun und da reicht es
nicht zu sagen bauen bauen bauen sondern
wir müssen eingreifen in den bestand
dass es dringend notwendig und das sind
wir den mieterinnen und mietern schuldig
sei schon jetzt dass die jungen haben wo
normale menschen die miete nicht zahlen
können dann haben wir einfach ein
problem der mieten deckel in berlin
wurde er vom verfassungsgericht für
illegal erklärt wird es mit ihnen in
welcher form auch immer einer koalition
garantiert keinen bundesweiten mieten
deckel geben
um noch mal auf die eine frage die immer
dort wurde eine klare antwort zu geben
ich bin dagegen dass wir jetzt
wohnungsunternehmen an der eignen ich
halte das nicht für den richtigen weg
das kostet sehr sehr viel geld und wir
sollten lieber neue wohnungen bauen und
ich glaube dass das auch wenn sie mir
das noch kurz gestatten die wichtigste
aufgabe ist wir haben es in deutschland
schon einmal geschafft 1973 war das
800.000 wohnung in einem jahr zu bauen
wir sind jetzt bei 300.000 wohnungen das
ist viel zu wenig wir müssen jedes jahr
und viele viele jahre lang 400.000
wohnungen bauen und darunter 100.000
sozialwohnung wir haben das grundgesetz
geändert damit wir das als bund weiter
fördern können für die mittel
bereitzustellen
und ich will gerne sagen das geht nur
wenn man sich mit allen zusammen
schließt mit der bauindustrie mit der
wohnungswirtschaft und noch die antwort
auf die frage die kommt mit der
wohnungswirtschaft mit den mieterinnen
und mietern und ihren organisationen mit
den städten und gemeinden mit den
landkreisen mit den ländern wir brauchen
ein großes bündnis für das wohnen in dem
wir das zustande bringen das ist mir
auch schon mal gelungen wenn ich das
sagen darf ich habe eine regierung an
und frage hat sich gestellt die antwort
kriegen sie euch es ist mir auch schon
einmal gelungen und das zu machen ich
habe eine cdu geführte regierung und
haben durch abgelöst die den wohnungsbau
verschlafen hatte jetzt sind da
mittlerweile über 100.000 wohnungen
genehmigt über 77.000 gebaut sehr viele
sozialwohnungen und malaria frage muss
ja gesagt werden und um ihre frage zu
beantworten
ich glaube dass wir die regeln unseres
mietrechts die wir heute schon haben
verstärken müssen die dazu beitragen
dass der mietanstieg begrenzt wird das
ist aber eine andere regelung als die
die in berlin die vier jahre halten sie
den deckel und die regelung die ich
richtig finde ist dass wir einmal die
mietpreis bremse die wir schon haben bei
neuvermietung verlängern entfristen und
die lücken die da drin sind schließen
und dass wir zum zweiten ein moratorium
machen das dazu führt dass der
mietpreisanstieg begrenzt ist es wird
auch mit erhöhung geben aber nicht so
einfach jetzt statt für ein garantiert
kein mieten deckel das ist das was ich
nicht will ich will ein moratorium und
das habe ich ihm gerade vorgestellt
noch heute zu sagen also das hat ja ein
bisschen gebraucht ist sie da die klare
antwort gegeben haben ihre partei hat
mit ihrer nachbarin zur linken und zur
rechten in berlin exakt das beschlossen
und in berlin hat rot rot grün vor
einigen jahren
65.000 wohnungen verkauft für 400
millionen euro und kauft jetzt 15.000
zurück für über 2 milliarden euro wenn
das eine kluge wohnungsbaupolitik ist
und sie sogar noch dagegen legen dass
man baut
dann erkenne ich habe gesagt er
kenne ich dass herr scholz mit seinen
partnerinnen über den grünen und bei den
linken irgendetwas dazu beiträgt dass
wir in deutschland mehr wohnungen haben
und dass wir vor allem sozial bezahlbare
wohnung nahm das konzert in berlin ihrer
partei war jedenfalls das falsche
laschet aber ich bin
nämlich über wir reden jetzt hat man das
nächste thema wo wir wahrscheinlich
ebenso in dem dürfen
wir machen nicht alle also das können
wir auch noch mal wird das fragen im
viele spielregeln wir werden nicht alle
immer zu allen fragen zu wort kommen
lassen aber
es ist ausgewogen wir werden auch nicht
immer eine uhr oder ein zeitkonto allen
blenden aber es gibt menschen die darauf
achten und das die zeit nehmen dass alle
gleich gemäßigt rankommen und jetzt
würden wir zu einem ähnlich engagierten
thema kommen wo wir darüber sprechen
nämlich über die finanzen der in
deutschland hat sich in der korona krise
massiv verschuldet und dazu kommt dass
wir den gesamten staat umbauen müssen
digitalisierung klimaziele es wird also
sehr viel geld kosten und vielleicht
wenn wir das jetzt alles ein bisschen
schneller behandeln weil wir auch noch
zur außenpolitik kommen wollen und zu
anderen wichtigen themen frau bärbel
dieses gesamte grüne programm beruht
letztlich darauf dass die schuldenbremse
aufgeweicht wird und deutlich mehr
schulden gemacht werden können mal
abgesehen davon dass sie dafür eine
zweidrittel mehrheit bräuchten ist das
gerecht ist das generationengerecht ja
weil wir ansonsten unseren kindern und
unseren enkelkindern ein marodes land
hinterlassen wir erleben jetzt schon
dass kinder nicht wirklich lernen
konnten weil es leider bei ihm zu hause
keinen funktionierenden
internetanschluss gab geschweige denn in
den schulen jede sechste brücke jede
sechste weiche jedes sechste gleich in
deutschland ist marode mit blick auf den
klimaschutz müssen ja massiv dafür
sorgen dass wir eine
wasserstoff-infrastruktur und den strom
leitungsausbau brauchen glauben wir
brauchen wir 50 milliarden jährlich
ansonsten bröckelt uns der ganze
wohlstand deutschlands in den nächsten
jahrzehnten dahin und deswegen ist unser
vorschlag die schuldenbremse die es
weiterhin geben wird durch eine
investitions regel zu erweitern damit
wir in unser land in die infrastruktur
in das was deutschland stark macht in
den nächsten jahren auch investieren und
unseren kindern mich ein kaputtes land
hinter länder das ausweichen der
schuldenbremse wäre das für sie als
künftiger möglicher künftiger
finanzminister ein ausschlusskriterium
für eine koalition ja fraglos das ist
nicht ratsam in der aktuellen situation
wir haben in deutschland ein hohes
defizit wir sind sehr stark verschuldet
in europa wir haben inzwischen sogar
inflationsrisiken die wir beobachten ich
bin in sorge dass unsere europäische
zentralbank auch gehindert sein könnte
gegen die inflation zu arbeiten wegen
der hohen verschuldung in europa deshalb
muss der weg von frau berbalk
ausgeschlossen werden aber es spricht ja
nichts dagegen investitionen
anzuschieben
insbesondere im privaten bereich frau
berbalk müssen die investitionen
erfolgen
digitalisierung und klimaschutz das sind
aufgaben der transformation auch der
privaten wirtschaft und deshalb ist der
vorschlag dass wir beginnen mit einem
super abschreibungs programm das
anlageinvestitionen der betriebe etwa
für klimafreundliche technologie der
digitalisierung binnen zwei jahren
abgeschrieben werden idealerweise
kombiniert mit einem gezielten
bürokratieabbau planungs beschleunigung
und wünschenswerter weise auch der
abschaffung des solidaritätszuschlags
und gestalten sie im zweiten gedanken
warum kommt niemand auf die idee statt
die steuern zu erhöhen oder die
schuldenbremse aufzuweichen einmal zu
fragen ob es nicht innerhalb des
staatshaushaltes ausgaben gibt die wir
nicht mehr brauchen hier ist ein
vorschlag wir haben eine exzellent
wettbewerbsfähige deutsche
automobilindustrie mit großartigen
produkten auch elektroautos warum wird
das noch mit so viel geld mit milliarden
subventioniert obwohl die konzerne
milliardengewinne machen bis zu 20.000
euro für ein elektrofahrzeug selbst für
den gutverdienern für die schülerinnen
geben wir als staat für ihre bildung pro
schuljahr 8000 euro aus mein vorschlag
diese subventionen streichen wenn man
bildungsinvestitionen verstärken würde
so weit werden sie da der meinung von
herrn lindner subventionen für autos
streichen
also erstmal das thema das wir eine
kostenkontrolle im bundeshaushalt
brauchen dass sie mit den ausgaben die
den deutschen steuerzahlern und bürger
nicht zugute kommen das ist ja das was
ich immer sage wir sind bei den kosten
viel zu hoch wir haben ein gigantisches
steueraufkommen und ich höre auch hier
in der diskussion immer nur die steuern
zu erhöhen wir müssen aber mit den
steuern runter wir müssen gerade die
liebe bürger die bürger richtig von
ihnen habe ich das nicht eher lindner
aber von den anderen höre ich dass wir
müssen mit den steuern und abgaben
runter um die kleinen und mittleren
einkommen um die familien zu entlasten
da müssen wir ansetzen und
dementsprechend sagen wie als afd ja
eben auch die co2 besteuerung ist auch
verfassungswidrig haben sie eingeführt
muss abgeschafft werden dadurch geht den
pendlern der spritpreis und die
heizkosten durch die decke das eeg
abgeschafft das ist etwas was wirklich
überhaupt nicht geht seit 2004
hat sich die hat sich das eeg fahrt
zehnfach und uns geht die energie die
preise durch die decke und wir müssen
natürlich mit der einkommensteuer runter
und dementsprechend müssen wir darüber
reden wie kommen wir auf der kostenseite
runtergehen und da fallen mir ganz viele
kosten größen 1 die kosten durch die
illegale migration der durch die eu
umverteilungspolitik corona wiederaufbau
vor aber das kann die arabischen raum
runter
doch auch diese frau hassel antworten
wie alle arbeiten auch das ist mir auch
die zeit nehmen denn sie haben die frage
nach dem finanzhaushalt gestellt genau
das hatten sie jetzt gemacht und das war
die frage und wir haben jetzt um
zurückzukommen mit zu finanzen und den
punkt abzubinden
eine gerne eine art schnelle fragerunde
an sie alle weil es den spagat abdeckt
und zwar wie entscheiden sie in den
kommenden jahren eher für einen
ausgeglichenen haushalt oder für nötige
investitionen fangen wir bei ihnen an
frau wissler wir brauchen investitionen
unbedingt den klimaschutz und
bezahlbares wohnen in die krankenhäuser
haben wir wieder gesehen aber wir
brauchen eine andere steuerpolitik
einsatz der politik um mehreinnahmen zu
haben deswegen spielt vermögenssteuer
vor sehr hoch wir haben für die wir
haben für die nächsten jahre 50
milliarden investitionen vorgesehenen
bundeshaushalt in der finanzplanung die
die bundesregierung einstimmig
beschlossen hat das ist das was wir
brauchen an öffentlichen investitionen
stimme herrn blind dazu das größte teil
dessen was wir brauchen bei windenergie
bei leitungsnetzen bei gigabit netze
mobilfunk sind privatwirtschaftliche
investitionen die da eine rolle spielen
aber den teil der öffentlich sein muss
können wir finanzieren und das heißt
auch dass wir im rahmen der regeln des
grundgesetzes in der lage sind eine
expansive investitionsstrategie zu
fahren ohne dass wir sie verletzten
den erwerber ausgeglichener haushalt
investitionen so wie jeder gute
unternehmer wirtschaftet bei konsumtiven
ausgaben muss der haushalt ausgeglichen
sein und bei investiven aufgaben sowie
ein unternehmen in maschinen investiert
und dafür kredite aufnimmt da muss es
auch investieren um ich kriege ich auf
ihn einst jetzt gehen wir
haben vor der pandemie erlebt keine
steuererhöhungen schuldenbremse
unterstadt hatte jedes jahr
mehreinnahmen weil die wirtschaft
gewachsen ist und viele menschen in
beschäftigung waren und das
unterscheidet mich von den drei linken
spd und grünen ich will keine
steuererhöhungen ich will die
schuldenbremse einhalten und ich will
alles tun dass wir wieder wachstum haben
damit wir wieder ressourcen haben um
dann zu investieren er sehe keine
aufweichung der schuldenbremse
steuersenkungen statt steuererhöhungen
um nämlich die private wirtschaft und
das private engagement der menschen zu
stärken immer wenn steuern erhöht
während gibt es am ende weniger
steuereinnahmen und wirtschaftlicher
misserfolg also ist das der zweite weg
der dritte keine europäische schulden
union zu machen wenn man einen großen
beitrag erbracht aber eine generelle
einstieg wie es von einigen in dem
portal parteiprogramm gewollt weil den
eurobonds und sms der falsche weg das
wollen wir auf keinen fall und das
letztes investitionen auf der einen
seite technologie haben hightech viel zu
machen bei investitionen in auch viele
soziale fragen ist um das wohngeld geht
dass er sich bei dem team wo noch
angebracht aber was nicht passieren kann
eine generelle umverteilungs idee zu
entwickeln
das ist das ganze was von linker seite
ganz bewusst in den raum gestellt wird
das führt am ende zum gleichen wie bei
gerhard schröder 25
ich habe mir erst ein bild sofort mit
dürfen deswegen bildeten ergänzen habe
viele gute trainer schon da passiert
genau das gleiche es geht genau los wie
bei lafontaine und schröder viele viele
ideen viele viele experimente am ende
stand das land kurz vor dem ruin das
darf nicht passieren
sehr sympathisch was der csu-vorsitzende
gerade gesagt hat der bayerische
ministerpräsident hat aber gerade
neulich in einer regierungserklärung im
landtag gefragt ob die schuldenbremse
nicht verfassungsrechtlich einmal
überprüft werden müssten also insofern
eine neue in neue interessante
information die csu ist wie soll ich
sagen im fluss was diese fragen wir
rechnen für mich ist für mich ist in die
schulden schuldenbremse muss eingehalten
werden ist übrigens etwas anderes als
ein ausgeglichener haushalt weil im
konjunkturverlauf die kreditaufnahme in
der verfassung ermöglicht ist auf der
anderen seite keine steuererhöhungen das
ist für meine partei ein konzept von
zwei leitplanken innerhalb der
leitplanken müssen wir alles unternehmen
dass wir einen aufschwung bekommen
deutschland wächst nur mit 2,5 prozent
andere kommen besser aus der krise also
bitte nicht neuen bürokratismus in
deutschland schnellere
genehmigungsverfahren
gezielte entlastungen und dann wachsen
dem staat auch wieder mittel zu die für
sinnvolle soziale und ökologische fragen
eingesetzt werden können
die bürger entlasten die arbeitende
bevölkerung deutlich entlasten durch
steuer und abgabensenkungen sowie ich
das eben ausgeführt habe und man hat
enorm viel luft dafür indem man auf der
ausgabenseite des haushalts einfach
einsparungen trifft die eben nicht der
bevölkerung zugute kommen sondern
ein teil der ausgaben sind die auch aus
meiner sicht völlig völlig unnötig sind
und vielleicht noch eins zu eins oder
ist das sehr interessant die cdu/csu ist
ja auch in der regierung sie hätten das
längst machen können die steuern zu
senken das haben sie nicht getan und ich
denke mal das ist es auch dem wahlkampf
geschuldet dass sie das hier noch mal
ausgeführt haben aber sie haben es ja
letztendlich nie umgesetzt und
vielleicht auch noch mal dazu da haben
sie dann eben auch luft beim sozialen
wohnungsbau dürfen wir ja eben nichts
dazu sagen aber ich noch ein satz liebe
frau hassel einsatz
die die bürokratisierung ist einfach zu
hoch auch da hätten die
regierungsparteien längst eingreifen
müssen dass wir schnellere
genehmigungsverfahren haben um eben also
das wurde er eben gar nicht angesprochen
darum ist es ja so dass zu sagen
vielen dank wir würden gerne zu einem
thema kommt es in diesem wahlkampf
unangemessener weise eigentlich kaum
eine rolle gespielt hat die viel
beschworenen zeitenwende hat ja auch
viel damit zu tun dass sich die welt um
uns herum fundamental verändert china
zeigt seine muskeln und uns unsere
abhängigkeit ein neuer kalter konfliktes
unterwegs welche rolle spielen wir darin
und zu welchem preis frankreich wurde
gerade bei einem gigantischen
rüstungsauftrag ausgebootet hat sogar
seinen botschafter aus den usa zurück
beordert herr scholz stehen sie an der
seite frankreichs und wie würden sie als
ein möglicher regierungschef damit
umgehen
wir müssen mit frankreich zusammen dafür
sorgen dass europa vorankommt und
deshalb haben wir hier auch eine die
partnerschaft das finde ich ist ganz
ganz wichtig und die irritation die die
französische regierung hat über die art
und weise wie das da gelaufen ist mit
dem neuen rüstungsvertrag denen die usa
mit australien und großbritannien auf
den weg gebracht haben für die
atomgetriebenen u-boote die kann ich
sehr nachvollziehen und auch die ganze
deutsche regierung im übrigen wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass wir ein starkes
souveränes europa bekommen das ist aus
meiner sicht die wichtigste aufgabe die
wir als deutsche haben wir sind das
große land mitten drin in der
europäischen union mit der größten
bevölkerung der größten wirtschaftskraft
und deshalb werden wir dafür sorge
tragen müssen dass dieses europa mehr
mit einer stimme sprechen kann die welt
wird mal zehn milliarden einwohner haben
da wird es viele mächte geben nicht nur
die usa china und russland sondern auch
viele andere länder des wieder
aufgeschriebenen steigenden asiens korea
japan indonesien malaysia indien um
einige zu nennen und aus meiner sicht
ist es deshalb ganz ganz zentral dass
wir immer sagen es gibt paar prinzipien
die für uns wichtig sind zudem zählt die
starke europäische union weil wir sonst
keine rolle spielen dazu zählt aber auch
die zusammenarbeit mit den usa gerade
auch wenn es zu kritisch würden wir
jetzt und dazu zählt natürlich auch die
zusammenarbeit in der nato wir haben
relativ viele fragen aus dem bereich
also insofern kurze antworten helfen uns
auch das thema breit aufzustellen herr
laschet schmollen die franzosen zu
unrecht wie ihr außenexperte norbert
röttgen gesagt hat und an sie als
potenziellen kanzler wie würden sie denn
mit welcher politik verhindern dass
europa zerrieben wird in diesem
kräftespiel zwischen den beiden
supermächten china und usa aber vielen
dank vorab unter kohl dass sie das thema
hier ansprechen m3 trainer gehabt aber
über diese frage außen europa
entwicklungspolitik ist so gut wie kein
wort gefallen ganz europa schaut darauf
was entsteht jetzt für eine neue
deutsche regierung weil deutschland
immer in europa ein wichtiger staat ist
der durch seine wirtschaftliche stärke
europa zusammenhält und
gleichzeitig eine politische macht ist
auf die viele schauen und deshalb glaube
ich dass wir
ein souveränes ein stärkeres europa
brauchen insbesondere in der außen und
sicherheitspolitik
in afghanistan gesehen wenn die
amerikaner abziehen sind wenn ich einmal
in der lage den flughafen von kabul zu
sichern deshalb will ich im
bundeskanzleramt einen nationalen
sicherheitsrat einrichten der alle
unsere informationen bündelt und die
außenpolitik stärkt und zum zweiten
brauchen wir mehr europa wir müssen mit
einer stimme sprechen wir müssen
gemeinsame projekte beginnen auch
rüstungsprojekte beginnen um auch einmal
handeln zu können wenn die usa sich
zurückziehen und da sie eine aufgabe die
die nächste regierung haben wird
probiert die militärischen drohungen im
südchinesischen meer die unterdrückung
der demokratie in hongkong
die uiguren sie fordern einen deutlich
härteren kurs gegenüber china was heißt
denn das konkret welchen hebel würden
sie ansetzen ja wir haben erlebt dass
durch die lücke die europa und das lag
vor allen dingen daran weil das größte
land in europa nämlich die
bundesrepublik deutschland ausgefallen
ist dass sich die lücke die europa
außenpolitisch schaffen hat autoritäre
kräfte nicht nur in china sondern wie
russland diese lücke gefüllt ausgefallen
meinen sie zu freundlich ja
beziehungsweise zu schweigsam oder eben
nicht gemeinsam als europäer agiert also
nehmen wir jetzt mal zum beispiel mit
blick auf die situation dass zu beginn
des jahres eine neue us-administration
gewählt worden ist die endlich diesen
neuen aufbruch für demokratien weltweit
einen neustart gegeben hat und was war
die erste reaktion von der
bundesregierung von der großen koalition
mit china eine investitions abkommen zu
schließen was im übrigen auch alle
anderen unsere euro eigenen europäischen
partner ein von latz geknallt hat weil
man das gar nicht gemeinsam in europa
beschlossen hat deswegen das
reichenberger auf eis nun ich möchte
dafür sorgen dass wir zu einer
gemeinsamen europäischen china politik
kommen nicht hinein gegen die andere
ausgespielt werden damit wir im
wettstreit dieser systeme als europa
deutlich machen wir haben eine eigene
strategische souveränität und das heißt
ein neues kapitel in der europäischen
außen- und auch menschen politik endlich
auf zu schlagen herr lindner sie haben
ja auch sie kennen sich in china aus sie
waren darunter weg sie haben oft die
china politik der kanzlerin kritisiert
als ich sie mit meinen worten zu
wirtschafts orientiert und zu unkritisch
gegenüber den menschenrechten das heißt
wenn sie sagen in einer regierung der
sie mit angehören würden wir müssen eine
härtere politik gegenüber china fahren
würden sie dann auch zu mitarbeitern von
unternehmen gehen den in die augen
schauen und sagen sorry aber ihr job
fällt vielleicht weg weil wir china
unter druck gesetzt haben volkswagen zum
beispiel verkauft fast jedes zweite auto
ins reich der mitte es gibt eine
alternative
noch dazu zunächst sehe ich das
investitionsabkommen mit china ebenfalls
kritisch wir müssen unsere interessen
und unsere werte gleichermaßen vertreten
ich bin sicher dass unsere produkte so
gut sind dass es von chinesischer seite
da keine zurückweisung gebe wir sollten
aber auch das klumpenrisiko wenn man das
mal so nennt handel mit china dadurch
reduzieren dass wir mehr
freihandelsabkommen schließen das
freihandelsabkommen mit kanada hat die
große koalition nicht vermocht in vier
jahren zu ratifizieren
wir brauchen mit südamerika mit den
asian staaten handelsabkommen damit auch
für den deutschen mittelstand der export
dahin erleichtert wird ich muss allen
damit verbundenen zweiten punkt machen
europa muss tatsächlich handlungsfähig
werden wir müssen den binnenmarkt als
wachstumsmotor stärken bei digitalen
dienstleistungen auch im bereich der
banken zweitens wir brauchen innerhalb
europas mehr gemeinsamkeit bei der
klimapolitik bitte nicht nur ein
deutscher sonderweg bei der frage der
migrationspolitik schutz der
aussengrenzen gemeinsame außen und
sicherheitspolitik
ich rate ab ich bin gleich gleich fertig
ich rate ab bei der vergemeinschaftung
von schulden oder beim gedanken dass nur
mit staatlichen investitionen wachstum
erfolgen könnte das wird nicht gelingen
letzter punkt die usa sind für uns ein
unverzichtbarer strategischer partner
und deshalb muss eine zukünftige
deutsche bundesregierung mehr tun um aus
einer europa perspektive das
transatlantische verhältnis zu
verbessern ein konkreter vorschlag es
gibt gemeinsame kabinettssitzungen der
bundesregierung mit china mit frankreich
mit israel warum gibt es so etwas nicht
mit unserem wichtigsten verbündeten der
usa bleiben wir gern noch beim thema
china herr söder der ausländische
berater der ehemalige berater der
kanzlerin hat bezeichnet china jetzt als
einen totalitären staat
mehr härte gegenüber china klingt ja gut
aber was bedeutet das und was sagen sie
dann arbeitern beispielsweise in münchen
die davon betroffen sind zunächst einmal
finde ich der eindruck vermittelt wird
dass deutschland seit vielen jahren
freiburg sei keine schlechte
außenpolitik nachweislich zurück ich
finde unsere bundeskanzlerin hat uns
durch schwerste krisen globale krisen
gut gebracht aber sie habe dieses land
einfach gut beschützt und hat an ansehen
im ausland muss ich manche wünschen
würden dass jeder im leben so ein
ansehen bekommen das erste
zwischen zu reden macht nicht richtiger
das zweite ist ich glaube dass wir uns
auf krisensituationen besser vorbereiten
müssen in der welt indem wir die
bundeswehr stärken das haben jetzt auch
in afghanistan wir haben asche zu recht
sagt deswegen wäre auch der einsatz
gegen bundeswehr abschaffung der
bundeswehr ausstieg aus der nato
katastrophales zeichen internationaler
unsicherheit würde und so in europa
komplett isoliert und dürfe auf keinen
fall passieren und ist dritter wir
brauchen eine außenpolitik die die
richtige balance zwischen den werten für
die wir stehen auch im wettbewerb der
systeme aber eben umgekehrt auch unsere
interessen jedes land der welt denkt
auch an seine interessen und wir in
europa müssen es auch tun und es sind
glaube ich einfach mit china braucht es
sicherlich einen konstruktiven dialog
nicht kuscheln aber es braucht auch
nicht eine komplette bewährungs dogmatik
das heißt natürlich müssen wir auch die
wirtschaftlichen interessen sehen die
wir da haben china ist unser wichtigster
markt gehen als nicht nur für automobil
wichtig und ehrlicherweise ich sehe
jetzt nicht an dass wir aufgrund mancher
ideen und auch eine etwas unreifen
einstellung zur welt wie vielleicht bei
den grünen dann am ende millionen
arbeitsplätze in deutschland gefährden
da braucht es eine richtige eine kluge
und eine strategische ausgewogenheit und
ob das jetzt naive frau wer mag da
werden sie sicher nicht was gegen sagen
wollen aber laden bdi hat da ja auch
eine klage in der auktion das war nicht
mit zwangsarbeiter auf den europäischen
binnenmarkt kommen sollte der dialog und
härte in der china politik genau der
richtige weg wir können die chinesen
haben würde
ins spiel bringen und frau weil das
wissen vielleicht nicht alle sie haben
ja in china gelebt in der zeit kennen
das land also auch und wir haben ja
gerade den dissenz eigentlich
menschenrechte auch über
wirtschaftspolitik mit anzusprechen oder
eben nationale interessen oder beides
geht beides deshalb ganz konkret für sie
wirtschaft für
beides also sie haben grundsätzlich wenn
sie einen handelspartner haben haben sie
auch interessen und diese interessen
müssen ausgeglichen werden im fall von
der bundesrepublik deutschland ist es so
dass die usa als auch die volksrepublik
china
unsere wichtigsten export absatzmärkte
sind und da ist muss ich eben auch weg
ist und das muss dass muss sich
natürlich auch in der außenpolitischen
interessen lage wieder schlag heißt das
dass wir zu beiden ländern gute
beziehungen brauchen und ich rate davon
ab vor allem
im fall von der volksrepublik china mit
einer keule so wie es frau berbalk hier
gerade angesprochen hat
darüber zukommen denn volks die
volksrepublik china ist viel zu wichtig
geworden und wird auch noch viel
wichtiger so dass wir ein entspannteres
verhältnis mit den chinesen brauchen was
ja auch im übrigen die bundesregierung
früher auch hatte weil sie eben auch
ganz klar die wirtschafts interessen
vertreten hat also verzichtet haben für
diese forschungs und entwicklungslabor
dort vor ort im übrigen in dem moment in
dem iris und kauf von moria unternehmen
wo wir reden genau und wo wir gerade
darüber moment ich lasse mich gerade
lassen sie mich diesen punkt machen
gerade wo wir darüber sprechen wird in
china der erste thorium reaktor gebaut
so viel zu forschungs und
entwicklungsleistungen der volksrepublik
china
das heißt wir können in einer
internationalen zusammenarbeit mit china
profitieren und wir können voneinander
lernen und ich rate davon ab in einen
dialog abzubrechen oder den chinesen vor
den kopf zu stoßen wollte daraus aber
für eine lege ich mir gefallen die worte
straßen möchte ja niemand ich bin nur
die frage noch mal wiederholen weil sie
glaube ich erhellend ist stehen wie
stehen sie dazu frau weiter dass mit
chinesischem kapital deutsche
unternehmen gekauft werden und das
europäischen unternehmen in gleicher
weise in china nicht möglich ist also
eine ganz kurze antwort an unseren
dritten moderator ja warum soll ich
darauf kurz antwort und wenn er mir so
eine lange frage stellt darauf kann man
ja auch vernünftig antworten oder also
erstmal gilt gilt gilt bei
kapitalinvestition der freie markt das
ist einfach so das wissen sie auch und
ich halte da eben auch überhaupt gar
nichts von dass wir kein verhältnis auf
dem investitions markt auf augenhöhe
haben und da ist natürlich auch wieder
die bundesregierung ist dort gefragt
dort für eine entspannung zu sorgen und
unsere design
genauso habe ich ja gerade schon vorbei
und herr lindner zur not nach der
sendung fortgesetzt wird wir haben
spontan visualität
haben erklärt in treffen frau winter
ihre partei wird ja kaum die position
vertreten wirtschaft zuerst sondern eher
die menschenrechte betont dennoch
hört man sehr wenig laute kritik von
ihrer partei und china
na ja ganz deutlich sagen wir dass
menschenrechte entscheidend sind und
auch die rechte von beschäftigten und
von gewerkschaften zum beispiel und das
ist auch an die adresse von deutschen
unternehmen der gute geschäfte machen in
china das die insbesondere die
arbeitnehmerrechte eingehalten werden
müssen ich will nur vielleicht kurze an
einer stelle herrn söder wir sprechen
wenn er sagt deutschland hat eine
erfolgreiche außenpolitik gemacht also
wir haben das desaster von afghanistan
gerade erlebt 20 jahre lang krieg 100000
zivile tote 12 5 milliarden euro hat
dieser bundeswehreinsatz geschossen und
jetzt die taliban wieder da und sie sind
stärker als je zuvor weil sie vermutlich
jetzt auf der ami zurückgreifen können
die 20 jahre lang ausgebildet und
ausgerüstet wurde vom westen der einsatz
in mali steht kurz vor dem scheitern
lassen sie uns darüber reden wenn du
über europäische union reden dass man
zulässt dass tagtäglich menschen im
mittelmeer ertrinken oder darüber dass
wie die deutsche politik ist war also
ich meine dass die türkei weiterhin
waffenlieferungen bekommt aus
deutschland nato-partner übrigens und
dort krieg gegen die kurden führt die
opposition und das weise ich kann nicht
feststellen dass diese bundesregierung
eine erfolgreiche außenpolitik gemacht
hätte es wäre völlig inhalte auch so
ziemlich alles andere hätte mich jetzt
auch bewundert unter hier war jetzt
mehrfach
schon gefallen und in der tat es war ja
schon angeklungen ist das ein
militärisches debakel die usa um uns vor
vollendete tatsachen gestellt mit diesem
unabgesprochenen über alten abzug aus
afghanistan herr söder sie waren jetzt
länger nicht in der runde deshalb die
erste frage an sie die kanzlerin hat
danach gesagt wir müssen in zukunft
einsätze kleiner fassen was heißt dass
nur noch deutsche soldaten in
auslandseinsätzen wenn unsere sicherheit
bedroht ist oder aber gibt es noch den
vernetzten ansatz bauen wir noch schulen
und brunnen je nachdem was sozusagen
auch die möglichkeiten sind also zum
einmal glaube ich bei afghanistan der
völlig überstürzten abzug der amerikaner
ist ja die ursache für all die ganzen
herausforderungen und das ist ja ein
schon ein schlag für die glaubwürdigkeit
des westens gewesen das haben wir auch
immer gesagt keine schuld daran übrigens
die bundeswehr und die soldatinnen
soldaten haben dort einen großartigen
dienst geleistet das muss man
ausdrücklich sein gegenüber auch den
familien der gefallenen sie haben
unglaublich viel dazu beigetragen und 20
jahre übrigens auch terrorismus zu
verhindern das muss man mal sagen die
frage welche ansprüche ansprüche während
stellen also für die bundeswehr ist die
hauptaufgabe sicherheit zu gewährleisten
wir können nation building probieren
aber es wird nicht überall klappen in
bestimmten teilen der welt darauf müssen
die einsätze auch präzisiert werden sie
müssen konkretisiert werden was der
auftrag ist ich glaube auch dass die
bundeswehr einen bestimmten bereichen
gleichberechtigt mit anderen partnern
wenn zum beispiel den französischen
partnern sind müssen wir die gleichen
robusten einsätze fahren und ich kann
nur eines sagen das wichtigste ist
überhaupt souveränität zu haben mehr
geld für die bundeswehr ich glaube 40
länder der welt haben bewaffnete drohnen
um ihre soldatinnen soldaten zu schützen
teile der spd haben das immer verhindert
ich halte es für falsch wir müssen die
beste technologie entwickelt und die
bundeswehr einen zustand versetzen
international dem status deutschlands
der größe dem schutz seiner eigenen
bürger dann am ende auch die sicherheit
und souveränität zu schließen wir die
frage an den finanzminister die
bundeswehr wurde ja so wird es von
kritikern gesehen jahre lang kaputt
gespart und ist relativ schlecht
ausgerüstet müssten wir jetzt nicht
sagen dass zwei prozent ziel der nato
ist eigentlich noch zu wenig um ein
funktionierendes sicherheitsbündnis ohne
die usa aufzubauen vielleicht sollten
wir mal bei den fakten bleiben die
bundeswehr hat erhebliche mittel
steigerung bekommen im laufe dieser
legislaturperiode was sich völlig
richtig finde scheint aber wir haben
recht wir haben eine steigerung in
dieser zeit von dem haushaltsentwurf den
ich übernommen habe für das jahr 2018
bis zu dem der für das nächste jahr
geplant ist von 36% da geht es um viele
viele milliarden die jedes jahr
zusätzlich fließen und ich halte das
auch für richtig weil die bundeswehr
hatte in der zeit das muss ich sagen der
schwarz gelben koalition ihre
schlechteste zeit da es wirklich
sparpolitik bei der bundeswehr gemacht
worden und das haben wir jetzt gründlich
beendet und das ist auch richtig so also
ich stimme zu wenn gesagt wird wir
müssen eine gute ausstattung der
bundeswehr organisieren stimme auch zu
was herr söder gesagt hat wir müssen
unseren soldaten soldaten sehr sehr
dankbar sein für den einsatz und die
einsätze diese überall in der welt
leisten das ist gefährlich und jedes mal
wenn wir diese entscheidungen im
bundestag treffen und wenn die
bundesregierung das vorschlägt müssen
wir immer im blick haben das wirklich
gefährliche einsätze auch die kleinen
und das darf nie vergessen werden und
deshalb sollten sie rege anderes dass
die das machen sie reden dass sie es so
gut machen sie reden alle jetzt davon
europa muss gestärkt werden wir müssen
uns auf eine neue zeit einstellen die
usa haben andere interessen dann reicht
das ja trotzdem nicht es ist erst mal
sehr viel geld und es ist auch das was
wir im vergleich zu den anderen nationen
die diese größenordnung haben leisten
können was wir bisher gemacht haben und
ich will gerne zu sagen dass wir im
rahmen der wirtschaftlichen
möglichkeiten auch in den nächsten
jahren weitere steigerung des
verteidigungshaushaltes brauchen nicht
dazu auch stehe dass das weiter so gehen
wird ich hatte ja gesagt wir haben die
kräfte die sozusagen die rede konnten
prüfen sie sind da relativ weit oben und
frau wissler ist relativ weit hinten
deshalb komme ich jetzt zu ihnen frau
wisse also wenn wir über den einsatz
deutscher soldaten im ausland treten
dann reden wir ja über auch und vor
allem über nato aus einsätze
eigentlich will die linke die nato
abschaffen jetzt macht die linke schon
gewisse morgan gaben vor
koalitionsgesprächen das macht man
eigentlich erst danach und ihr kandidat
bartsch hat sich da flexibel gezeigt hat
gesagt naja die nato auflösung sei eine
langfristige vision und nichts für die
kommende legislaturperiode hat er das
mit ihnen abgesprochen sehen sie das
genauso das sind keine wie sie es jetzt
genannt haben irgendwie zu gehen auf
andere sondern das ist die
gleichstellung unserer position so wie
sie im programm drin steht dass wir
gesagt haben ja wir kritisieren die nato
halten die nato für völlig über kommen
und wir halten es für notwendig dass wir
zu einer anderen sicherheitsarchitektur
kommen wir kritisieren sehr konkret zwei
punkte das ist das 2 prozent man muss
das ja mal plastisch machen was das
bedeuten würde deutschland gibt im
moment 50 milliarden euro aus für die
rüstung das wären dann noch mal 25
milliarden extra muss man aber ja nur
wissen was das heißt wir sind der
meinung mehr rüstung hat die welt nicht
sicherung wir brauchen das geld auch
dringend woanders haben wir beim krone
gesehen ein pflegenotstand wir haben
gute schulen wir haben zu wenig
bezahlbaren wohnraum wir wollen nicht 25
milliarden mehr für die rüstung ausgeben
bewaffnete drohnen lehnen wir strikt ab
wir haben es übrigens afghanistan gerade
gesehen
dafür redet konto sehr weit unten war
das war ja das aufgeholt das haben jetzt
aufgeholt aber noch mal konkret also
auch sie sagen nato auflösung ist eine
langfristige vision vision wäre nix
finanzteil die bundesregierung selbst
wenn ihr einer meinung wäre nicht auf
einen schlag die nato auflösen kann das
ist ja nur jetzt mit binsenweisheit wir
wollen gerne darüber reden dass wir das
2 prozent ziel wir wollen nicht weiter
aufrüsten und wir würden gerne wissen
wie wir mit der türkei umgehen die nun
mal ein nato-partner ist werden der
weiter waffen geliefert er schaut man da
weiter weg bei der
menschenrechtssituation um grundsätzlich
der meinung dass werden über
außenpolitik geredet werden vielleicht
nicht immer nur beim militär
verteidigung nato reden sollten sondern
mal über die internationalen klimaschutz
nicht über die weltwirtschaftsordnung
über freihandelsabkommen
also das sind ja auch ist nicht die
internationale show die den vergleich
und wir haben auch gar nicht die ganze
zeit darüber geredet und damit wir haben
auch gar nicht vorgeworfen allgemeinen
diskurs findet das sehr stark eine
verengung auf diese militärischen fragen
statt sie haben ja eben aber die
freihandelsabkommen explizit geredet
wird dass ich auch einen wichtigen punkt
von entwicklungszusammenarbeit zum
beispiel das 0,7 prozent ziel erreichen
statt den zwei prozent so die nase gut
damit wir möglichst viele themen noch
ansprechen können wir reden schon lange
über außenpolitik aber machen wir eine
schnell fragerunde mit unterschiedlichen
themen und
zwar zunächst an sie frau bislang wie
hätten sie persönlich wenn sie im
bundestag wehren abgestimmt ortskräfte
durch die bundeswehr aus kabul
ausfliegen lassen ja oder nein im juni
haben wir dazu einen antrag eingebracht
dem haben wir zugestimmt die grünen an
dem zug stuttgarter kreuz hatte hatte er
ja und mit nein gestimmt deshalb würde
ich mich interessieren hinter genau wir
haben es ja rechtzeitig beantragt und
soll nachträglich mandatierung als die
abstimmung stattfinden dass der
bundeswehreinsatz schon beendet war
daher wenig enthalten weil ich bin für
die evakuierung ich habe kritik an der
art und weise wir umsetzen und deswegen
hatte ich mich enthalten aber wir haben
das format ist ja oder nein
herr scholz atombomben aus deutschland
abziehen ja oder nein
wir haben internationale verpflichtungen
die wir einhalten müssen es gibt keine
einseitigen entscheidung aus deutschland
frau berg bewaffnete drohnen für die
bundeswehr ja oder nein
wenn geklärt ist für welche einsätze wer
sie brauchen weil die große lehre aus
afghanistan ist dass man vor einsätzen
definiert was sind eigentlich unsere
ziele was brauchen wir an material das
heißt dafür müssen die kriterien
entsprechend geschaffen werden damit
dann der einsatz auch sinn machen kann
dass sonja das war ein jahr mit den
kriterien die man dafür braucht weil
blankoschecks in der außenpolitik zu
verteilen ohne zu wissen für welche
situation ist hochriskant und das sollte
man nicht tun erläuterte nord stream in
betrieb nehmen ja oder ja wir brauchen
dich mal was wirtschaftliche projekt
weil wir wenn wir aus allen energien
aussteigen wenn natürlich in den
nächsten jahren gas brauchen wichtig ist
mir dass das was die bundesregierung
verabredet hat jetzt auch umgesetzt wird
nämlich eine geopolitische garantie dass
die ukraine dadurch keine nachteile
erleiden hat sollte ausland das sind
frage stellen wird das projekt
unmittelbar gestoppt herr söder
seenotrettung durch die eu wieder
einführen ja oder nein hilfe ja aber
gleichzeitig auch schutz der grenzen und
insbesondere mehr hilfe vor ort ist das
allerwichtigste übrigens auch mit den
anrainerstaaten in afghanistan hilfe vor
ort das ist die beste hilfe damit sich
niemand auf den weg machen muss aber
seenotrettung wieder einführen habe ich
nicht verstanden ja hier helfen immer
wieder aber nicht sozusagen eine
grundlegende veränderung der derzeitigen
politik herr lindner ukraine in die nato
ja oder nein nein
endlich mal einer mit einer klaren ja
oder nein
hinterher
polen um jeden preis in der eu halten ja
oder nein ja
auch ein kleines ja wunderbar vielen
dank fast alle parteien lassen ist bei
unserem nächsten thema nicht an großen
worten fehlen den klimawandel zu stoppen
ist eine menschheitsaufgabe heißt es bei
der spd die grünen sprechen von der
existenz frage unserer zeit die union
von der bewahrung der schöpfung zu der
das christliche menschenbild
verpflichtet
wir wollen gerne noch mal eine schnelle
fragerunde anschließen nur durch
innovation also ganz ohne verzicht wird
man die erderwärmung ja nicht aufhalten
können deswegen ungefähr eine frage an
sie alle was verzichten sie ganz
persönlich froh wenn wir bei ihnen
anfangen dürfen jetzt schon
auf unnötige strecken mit dem fahrzeug
dann benutze ich lieber das fahrrad und
auf sparsamkeit im verbrauch von
ressourcen
ich teile ihre voraussetzungen der frage
nicht milliarden menschen auf der welt
können nicht auf wohlstand oder
wirtschaftliche perspektive verzichten
weil sie gar keine haben deshalb ist die
aufgabe deutschlands durch
spitzentechnologie eine freie
lebensweise wirtschaftliche perspektive
mit dem klimaschutz zu verbinden und die
nation der ingenieurin und techniker
kann das vom wasserstoff windpark über
den synthetischen kraftstoffen
ich bin persönlich ich bin persönlich
klimaneutral weil ich jedes jahr die
tonnen co2 die ich persönlich
verbraucher im europäischen
zertifikatehandel ja schon lange
also ich glaube auch fest daran dass
nicht verzicht die frage sondern
veränderungen und dass verbote von
vornherein es falsche sind müssen die
angebote setzen ich persönlich war wie
heute beispielsweise mit der bahn her
statt mit dem auto ich hatte auch eine
video schalte gerne gemacht aber das
hätte man nämlich falsch ausgelegt und
umgekehrt auch ich reduziere auch und es
fehlt an den bayern gar nicht so leicht
den fleischkonsum beispielsweise und
gesünder und auch klimabewusste auch
mich zu ernähren wie gesagt ich bin auf
dem weg dazu richtig auskennen keiner
etwas gibt es bei ihnen selbst das tue
ich auch alles nicht bayer
ansonsten sind ja vielleicht ja aber
nicht
und ich teile aber ebenso diese
verzichts
verzichts gefühl nicht ich war ein
elektromobil das fahrzeug und das macht
spaß das ist schöner als das fahrzeug
das ich vorher hatte und deshalb glaube
ich dass das alles auch spaß machen kann
klimaneutral zu werden im regen stahl
warum nennen das einsparungen wie auch
immer ja das spare ich ein aber das
macht dazu noch spaß
jetzt alle solche öko sind ist ja schön
wenn die nächste bundesregierung dann
auch endlich klimaneutral wird ich fahre
seit sieben wochen im wahlkampf mit dem
bus durch die gegen auch gerne mal
nachts um im inland nicht zu fliegen mit
ihrem wahlkampf bus
ich finde man muss sehr vorsichtig sein
mit so einer antwort ich könnte jetzt
sagen auch wahrheitsgemäß und richtig
ich kaufe gerne regionale lebensmittel
ein das ist ein beitrag dazu aber ich
finde es gehört auch zur ehrlichkeit
dazu dass man als ein politiker der mit
sicherheits geschützten fahrzeugen
unterwegs ist mit vielen flugzeugen
pflicht nicht den eindruck erweckt als
sei man der beste beim reduzieren des
co2 abdrucks das ist etwas das ich als
zynisch empfinden würde ich finde
wahrheit hilft hier auch
nicht mit dem fahrrad ins ministerium
fahre was sich drei oder vier mal
gemacht habe dann sind auch noch viele
andere dabei und das ist keine
verbesserung der klimasituation ist gut
für mich und deshalb finde ich muss man
da ehrlich sein damit kein falscher
eindruck entsteht ich will aber
loswerden wir werden der gleiche
vielleicht nur darüber diskutieren dass
ich auch glaube dass das wichtigste was
wir zum schutz des klimas machen müssen
innovationen sind wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass wir die erneuerbaren
energien ausbauen damit wir den strom
bekommen den wir benötigen damit des co2
neutralen stahl co2 114 gibt damit für
klimaneutrale zement wirtschaft haben
automobilwirtschaft und maschinenbau das
geht auch wir können also wirklich ein
besseres leben führen ohne einschränkung
der schau dir reden gerne 740 ist frage
nach zu ende führen frau wisse worauf
verzichten sie persönlich oder sparen
ein
hier denke ich vernünftig mit energie um
und benutzten öffentliche verkehrsmittel
wann immer das gilt sowohl im
fernverkehr der bahn als auch im op en v
was sie aber auch gar nicht so unbedingt
als verzicht
begreifen würde sondern oftmals geht es
ja auch deutlich schneller ja und ich
bin seit vielen jahren aktiv in
klimaschutz bewegung die auch morgen
wieder auf die straße gehen weil ich
glaube dass es notwendig ist die
menschen die sich engagieren auch zu
unterstützen ob das gegen abholzung von
wäldern ist oder für die einhaltung der
klimaschutzziele eben auch dort diese
protestbewegung zu unterstützen gut dann
heller schavan jetzt in der persönlichen
runde schon ein bisschen gemischt aber
kommen wir zu was wirklich ernsten
politischen diese bundesregierung hatte
hat sich ein klimagesetz gegeben in dem
sie sich verpflichtet hat sofort
maßnahmen zu erlassen um gegenzusteuern
wenn bei den einzelnen sektoren die
ziele gerissen werden die werden im
moment drastisch gerissen wo bleiben die
sofortmaßnahmen wo wollen sie
gegensteuern
die bundesregierung fragen ja
ich kann ihnen sagen was wir machen
werden wenn ich bundeskanzler bin wir
werden das klimaschutzgesetz mit seinem
sektoren in jedem bereich
angleichen müssen durch maßnahmen
unterlegen müssen der co2 preis ist ein
einstieg werden weitere vorgesehen
welche aber entscheidend ja jetzt kommt
mein argument eben entscheidend ist
nicht in dem klein klein der maßnahmen
zu bleiben
sich die regierung sie leben ja wir
wollen aber doch klimaschutzziele
erreichen eben und wir wollen co2
reduzieren und wenn es uns deshalb
gelingt und da sind wir mittendrin
stahlproduktion nicht mehr mit kohle und
eisen erster mit wasserstoff zu machen
die chemische industrie umzugestalten
unsere industrien umzugestalten
dann leisten da gleichzeitig den
ausstieg aus den fossilen brennstoffen
wie der braunkohle jetzt voranzutreiben
dann leisten wir dazu einen
substanziellen beitrag um die ziele des
klimaschutzgesetzes zu erreichen das ist
die aufgabe man kann das noch mal alles
in sektoren klein herunterrechnen herab
ich will nur verstehen und dann gar
nicht weiter aufhalten daran können nein
aber ich will sie verstehen dass das was
sie sagen es das sind maßnahmen aber es
sind nicht die die das klimagesetz der
jetzigen regierung sich gegeben hat also
würde dieses gesetzlichen am kanzler das
muss ja ganz konkret kommen ja aber ich
war ich deshalb habe ich dieses
klein-klein in gesetzen zu denken muss
man erfüllen aber die aufgabe ist eine
viel größere die aufgabe ist eine
größere unsere industriegesellschaft
umzuwandeln 6 prozent des co2 ausstoßes
in deutschland ist stahl wenn uns das
gelingt ist das ein so großer schub und
wir sind ja mittendrin in diesem prozess
dann wird das mehr erreichen als viele
kleine maßnahmen die wir darauf
geschrieben aber wer trotzdem müssen die
erfüllt werden und an denen wird ja auch
stück für stück von jedem ressort
gearbeitet frau bär bei der exekutive
zieht man wenn wir bei exekutiven
defiziten sind wenn man sich zwei
bundesländer anschaut wo sie entweder
den ministerpräsidenten stellen oder
auch an der regierung beteiligt sind
werden da auch nicht mehr windräder
gebaut
weil die regelung für die kraft die
zentrale weichenstellung findet auf
bundesebene statt und genau das ist
jetzt die frage bei dieser
bundestagswahl
schaffen wir so wie andere generationen
bei historischen momenten in unserer
geschichte auch einen echten aufbruch
beschreiben erschaffen haben weil die
mutig gesagt haben wir schlagen jetzt
ein neues kapitel auf schaffen wir das
jetzt auch als zukünftige generation
deutschland in den nächsten 20 jahren
klimaneutral zu machen und das ist die
aufgabe unserer zeit und das bedeutet
jetzt ein klimaschutz sofort programm
aufzulegen 100 tage sofortprogramm wo
wir für jeden einzelnen sektor und das
unterscheidet uns grün von der cdu das
unterscheidet uns von der spd für jeden
einzelnen sektor sagen das müssen wir
jetzt tun kohleausstieg vorziehen
emissionsfreie autos landwirtschaft in
den nächsten 20 jahren klimaneutral
gebäude und stahl und das ist nicht nur
eine frage von klimaschutz sondern das
ist mittlerweile auch eine frage von
unserer internationalen
wettbewerbsfähigkeit yam gerade über
china geredet und china hat jetzt der
film nicht im ausland keine
kohlekraftwerke mehr zu finanzieren
sondern in zukunft energie partnerschaft
dem erneuerbaren bereich zu machen das
heißt aber in relief nicht als erster
kontinent klimaneutral werden als
europäerinnen und europäer dann
verpassen wir unsere historische chance
sowie generationen vor uns für den
wohlstand in deutschland gut herein
klimagerechten wohl stellte herr lindner
sie hatten schon portugals gesagt jetzt
als frau baerbock geredet hat deshalb
frage ich sie ich weiß die fdp das haben
sie auch gerade gesagt sagt setzt auf
innovation das ist auch richtig und
wichtig so aber man kann nicht planen
wann erfindungen und innovationen
funktionieren und greifen wir haben aber
eine großem zeitdruck dabei den haben
wir gerade festgestellt was also wenn
die große innovation auf sich warten
lässt sind denn die konkreten maßnahmen
der fdp um irgendwie noch das pariser
klima abkommen einzuhalten weil das
pariser klimaabkommen werden wir nur
globale einhalten können das kann
deutschland nicht alleine wir können
einen wertvollen beitrag leisten ich
glaube wie eben gesagt in dem modell
standort für bestimmte technologien sein
können und werden die woanders
eingesetzt werden da müssen wir richtig
vorgehen wenn frau baerbock über china
spricht dann darf sie nicht davon
schweigen das in deutschland daimler
erklärt keine verbrennungsmotoren mehr
zu bauen aber in china ein motorenwerk
für verbrennungsmotoren baut daimler
das zeigt wir brauchen eine globale
perspektive ist der vorschlag war zu
planen und zeitdruck was sind brauchen
ganz nahe hassel die die maßnahmen und
innovationen liegen doch vor denken sie
an basf und rwe die wollen den größten
co2 emittenten unseres landes den
chemiewerk das chemiewerk in
ludwigshafen ein prozent der gesamten
deutschen co2 emissionen aus dem werk
das wollen die elektrifizieren und
dekarbonisierung wissen sie was die
sagen sie brauchen kein geld vom staat
die bitten auch nicht um geduld die
verlangen nur schnelle planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren und da sehe ich
die aufgabe wir müssen nicht wie frau
berbalk das angeregt hat alles noch
weiter plan staatlich zentral lenken in
jedem sektor aber die werbe
planungssicherheit die sage ja noch mal
gerade was die was die wirtschaft
tatsächlich will die wollen nicht diese
sektor ziel es ist viel zu kleinteilig
csu und spd haben zu verantworten dass
im bereich der mobilität die sektor
ziele de facto nicht erreichbar sind mit
egal was man macht in den nächsten
jahren die sektor ziele in der mobilität
nicht erreichbar also wir brauchen ein
co2 limit technologieoffenheit und dann
gibt es viele die privates kapital und
know how haben die in klimaschutz
investieren wollen in ihrem wahlprogramm
steht sogar warm zeiten hätten immer zu
einer blüte des lebens und der kulturen
geführt hat der klimawandel muss sich
der afg also eher positive folgen wir
sagen
als afd dass es den klimawandel
also wärme und kälteperioden immer schon
gegeben hat und dass es überhaupt keinen
grund gibt in deutschland unseren
industriellen kern zu schleifen wir
wandeln ja nicht herr laschet unsere
industrie um sondern sie machen unsere
industrie kaputt und da sie jetzt auch
gerade den stahlmarkt erwähnt haben ich
war heute in einer gießerei in sachsen
und ich weiß nicht ob sie eine
vorstellung haben wie es dieser
industrie in deutschland geht sie machen
mit ihrer politik diese leute diese
gießereien diese industrie kaputt sie
schalten kohlekraftwerke die modernsten
stehen im übrigen in deutschland
schalten sie ab sie schalten die
kernkraftwerke ab sie gehen ein
sonderweg der überhaupt nicht nachhaltig
ist noch einmal ich habe das immer
wiederholt sie verbauen den weg für
forschungs- und entwicklungsleistungen
hier wird die atomkraft als
brandgefährliche dinosaurier technologie
dargestellt aber wie verpassen den
anschluss an die neuen generation ich
hab das eben schon ausgeführt ein
thorium reaktor wir gerade in china
gebaut wird
lassen sie mich aus führen
vielleicht ist das schon aufgefallen ich
möchte gerne ausführen was ein thorium
reaktor kann es kommt nicht das ist aber
nicht das thema dieser sind
entschuldigung entschuldigung herr kohl
das ist aber genau der punkt wir reden
hier immer um den heißen brei herum wir
schleifen den industriellen nachfrage
nicht reduzieren das ist kaffee mattos
ich habe ich habe gesagt den klimawandel
hat es immer schon gegeben und es gibt
überhaupt keinen grund unseren
industriellen kern sagt es wäre die
forschung entwicklung und die linke ist
bei ihrer forderung mit den klimaschutz
noch ambitionierter hinten in london zu
werden sie haben ihre antwort gegeben
vielen dank
frau wissler die linke hat ist bei ihren
forderungen zum klimaschutz noch
ambitionierter als die grünen sie wollen
nämlich schon 20 30 mindestens 80
prozent weniger co2 als
1990 wie soll denn das gehen zumal sie
ja auch mit recht sagen es muss
unbedingt sozialverträglich sein ja
unbedingt und wir haben uns natürlich
angeschaut wie können wir die pariser
klimaschutzziele einhalten und dass es
wie dringlich ist haben wir gerade
diesen sommer gesehen durch die
waldbrände durch die überschwemmungen
und deswegen müssen wir dringend handeln
wir brauchen und zum einen müssen wir
dringend die verkehrswende angehen wir
brauchen wir müssen deutschland zum
brand machen wirklich strecken
reaktivieren die stillgelegt wurden in
den letzten jahren bahnhöfe wieder
reaktivieren damit menschen eine
alternative zum auto haben wir könnten
zum beispiel sofort da sind wir drei uns
ja einig das tempolimit durchsetzen auf
autobahn wäre auf einen schlag zwei
millionen tonnen co2 die man auf einen
schlag ohne irgendwelche kosten
einsparen könnte der zweite punkt ist
die leute den klimawandel das ist sagt
ihnen zu diskutieren da habe ich aus ein
herstellungs- der sind wir müssen raus
aus der kohle und zwar vor 2038 wir
wollen raus aus der kohle jetzt
beginnend bis 2030 wir müssen sofort
aufhören wälder abzuholzen für
autobahnprojekte für flughafen projekte
weil männer darum richter alphons orie
soll das sozial abgefedert werden wir
brauchen eine wir brauchen eine soziale
abfederung was bedeutet dass wir nicht
die menschen die sowieso schon wenig
haben am stärksten belasten dürfen und
deswegen halten wir es für notwendig
dass wir zum beispiel bei den
fahrpreisen im öpnv ansetzen also da die
deutlich günstiger zu machen damit
menschen auch die möglichkeit also nicht
das autofahren grund erst mal teurer
sondern die pnv billiger damit die
menschen auch wirklich umsteigen können
und wir brauchen alternativen und
natürlich müssen wir die arbeitsplätze
in der industrie schützen deswegen
schlagen wir einen
transformationsprozess
weiterbildung umrüstung der industrie
weil wir deutschland ist ein
industrieland soll es auch bleiben das
brauchen wir gerade wenn wir die
energiewende durchsetzen wollen die
verkehrswende dann brauchen industrie
das ist ganz logisch dass machen und
auch im
bereich der landwirtschaft brauchen wir
natürlich auch eine wende also ab der
von der massentierhaltung wir würden
jetzt gern
noch in die zukunft schauen nämlich in
die zukunft der regierungs möglichkeiten
für viele wähler dürfte es ja bei der
stimmabgabe auch wichtig sein welche
koalition sich am ende bilden dürften
verwalten sie können sich jetzt im
moment entspannen weil moment ja keine
andere partei mit der fdp koalieren
möchte
also oder warum beschneiden sie die
möglichkeiten der union 1976 wurde auch
von platz zwei eine regierung gebildet
wir haben ein ganz klares ziel dass
armin laschet kanzler wird und der
überzeugendste regierungsauftrag gibt
sich mit einem klaren platz nummer eins
und wenn ich die demos kopiert der
letzten tage so sie gehe ich eher
letzter davon aus dass dieses noch
möglich ist möglich ist die spd
abzufangen märkte auch durch solchen
duellen die hier stattfinden oder wie
man das jetzt ein ende merkt man welche
richtung es geht auch wie gemeinsam
argumentiert wird wie ich glaube dass
ein linksbündnis das gewollt ist und ein
linksbündnis das möglich ist am ende
unserem land schweren schaden zufügen
wird und das muss man wissen und eine
bürgerliche regierung am ende des bestes
was die zukunft und zwar sowohl die
erneuerung als auch die stabilität
gewährleistet und ich gehe davon aus
dass wir die nummer eins werden davon
bin ich fest überzeugt bei aus wenn dann
auf platz eins ist muss man nicht über
platz zwei werden ganz einfach er herr
laschet erspare ich ihn nicht also sie
werden jetzt auch sagen natürlich gehen
sie davon aus dass sie auf platz eins
kommen theoretisch konjunktiv für den
fall sie käme die union käme auf platz
zwei würden sie dann trotzdem versuchen
eine regierung zu bilden und sondieren
also stehe er fordert frage wenn die spd
auf platz zwei kommt ob sie wie schon
angedeutet trotzdem ein rot-rot-grünes
bündnis spd fragen stellen auch gleich
ist ja die relevante frage über die die
wähler jetzt entscheiden müssen wird die
union so stark dass exakt diese
koalition nicht möglich wird wir haben
heute vom stellvertretend
spd-parteivorsitzenden gelesen dass er
einen mitgliederentscheid machen will
über die koalition eher scholz was ja
er muss doch nur eineinhalb oder zwei
asse wir wollen regieren dieses land und
die entscheidung die die bäder in
nottwil am kommenden sonntag fällen
müssen ist nicht wer wie aus 102 was
macht sondern ob wir in eine lage
rutschen dass ein solches bündnis
möglich wird dieser stellvertretende
parteivorsitzende namens kühnert hat
gesagt wenn man ein mitgliederentscheid
herr lindner sei ein luftikus die fdp
hat er dann noch in anderen dingen
beschrieben und damit ist da erkennbar
worum es geht dass spd grüne und linke
eine mehrheit bilden wollen und wir tun
alles dass es dazu nicht aber wenn es
noch ein knappes ergebnis wir sind nicht
beim wenden wir sind drei tage vor der
wahl und ich würde vorschlagen
und dann fragen
scholz sie waren ja schon mehrfach
angesprochen herr scholz also wir
bleiben ja dabei das war ja das was
jetzt also wenn sie auf die einst
konsultieren sie sowieso aber wir waren
ja jetzt bei der frage was wäre denn
wenn die spd auf den zweiten platz
landen sollte würden sie denn dann
gleichzeitig mit grünen und fdp oder mit
grünen und den linken koalieren oder in
welcher reihenfolge greifen sie da
zuhörer und ihre künftigen partner an
ich glaube das ist doch in der tat die
situation die auch meine beiden
vorredner schon beschrieben haben die
bürgerinnen bürger entscheiden wer der
nächste kanzler wird das tun sie auch
dadurch dass sie ihre stimme abgeben und
ich setze mich dafür ein dass das was
die umfragen jetzt
als möglich erkennen lassen auch
tatsächlich passiert nämlich dass es ein
sehr sehr starkes votum für die spd gibt
und dass sich daraus den auftrag
ableiten kann eine regierung zu führen
und für mich gibt es dabei eine ganze
reihe von rahmenbedingungen zudem zählt
insbesondere das mit den grundfunktionen
unseres staates nicht gespielt wird ich
sag das mal sehr klar wir brauchen einen
verfassungsschutz den wir auch in
deutschland weiter stärken müssen wir
brauchen die zusammenarbeit in der nato
wir brauchen ein gutes verhältnis zu den
vereinigten staaten von amerika wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass wir ordentlich
mit dem geld umgehen und dass die
wirtschaft wächst dass die sicherheit im
innern funktioniert und werden starke so
wird in die europäische union haben wir
müssen auch dafür sorgen dass die
bundeswehr sowie in den letzten jahren
weiter ausreichend ausgestattet wird all
das gehört zu den dingen die zum
regieren in deutschland dazu gehören
dann fragen wir doch gleich frau wissen
hat die gerade indirekt angesprochen
wurde ist das alles für sie
unterschreibt war
wir kämpfen jetzt dafür die linke
gestärkt sondern es gibt ja genug punkte
die uns auch von der spd unterscheiden
und das gibt sehr gute gründe warum ist
uns als partei gibt warum wir zum
beispiel kritisieren dass jetzt gerade
der mindestlohn um zehn cent erhöht
wurde und hat hier um drei euro was er
eine kürzung erhöhung ist und mit dem
respekt der versprochen ist nicht so
viel zu tun hat aber ich sag mal so wenn
herr scholz eine seriöse finanzpolitik
bildern bin ich sehr gespannt wie er sie
mit herrn lindner der 90 milliarden
steuerentlastung vorschlägt und
gleichzeitig die steuer die
schuldenbremse einhalten will wie sie
das mit herrn
lindner durchsetzen wollen oder die
frage gesetzlicher mindestlohn erhöhen
wo aus der kohle das sind punkte da
haben wir übereinstimmung wir haben auch
eine ganze menge differenzen aber ich
bin der meinung wir müssen schluss
machen mit der politik der verlorenen
zeit es gibt eine ganze menge menschen
in diesem land die am abend vor der
altersarmut die können sie ihre wohnung
nicht mehr leisten wir müssen beim
klimaschutz vorankommen deswegen bin ich
der meinung dass wenn die drei parteien
nach der wahl eine rechnerische mehrheit
haben dass es dann dringend notwendig
ist und alle drei in der verantwortung
sind darüber zu reden wie man zu einem
politikwechsel kommt damit man dieses
land in zukunft sicher macht die renten
sichert und dafür sorgt dass die soziale
spaltung in diesem land nicht immer
weiter auseinandergeht darüber würde ich
gerne reden jetzt kämpfen wir für eine
starke linke weil wir natürlich eine
ganze menge position haben wo wir freuen
uns auch sehr stark unterscheiden probe
wird machen sie da mit und reden sie mit
beiden seiten der demokratinnen und
demokraten sollten immer miteinander
reden und das ist unsere verantwortung
jetzt und das schöne ist wir leben in
einem freien land wir leben in einer
demokratie wo menschen frei entscheiden
können wo menschen vor gut 30 jahren in
ostdeutschland auf die straße gegangen
sind und gesagt haben so jetzt ist der
moment wo wir neuen mut aufbringen um
auch in freiheit in rechtsstaatlichkeit
und demokratie zu leben und genau da
stehen wir jetzt bei dieser größten
schlachtfelder wo sie am meisten
herausholen können wagen wir einen
echten neuen aufbruch cdu und spd stehen
für weiter so wir als grüne sagen jetzt
ist die zeit
ein neues kapitel aufzuschlagen beim
klimaschutz und ja ich bin zutiefst
davon überzeugt wir können deutschland
modernisieren wir können klimagerechten
wohlstand schaffen und das machen wir
mit den parteien mit denen es am besten
gelingt und solaris auch ohne eine
starke grüne führung ist es wie klima
ohne schutz das funktioniert am ende
nicht aber am ende funktioniert auch
keine regierung stand jetzt ohne die fdp
deshalb noch zu ihnen herr lindner
im moment wie weit dürfte egal wir um
das rennen jetzt ausgeht der
zweitplatzierte denn zurückliegen damit
sie mit ihm verhandeln und sondieren
oder sondieren sie offen beide varianten
ampel und jamaika wir sind in einer ganz
neuen phase frau hassel mit an
sicherheit grenzender wahrscheinlichkeit
wird die stärkste partei
2021 dennoch von über 70 prozent der
deutschen nicht gewählt worden sein
daraus leitet sich scholz also eben kein
klarer regierungsbildungsauftrag ab es
geht dann um gespräche danach und wir
wollen möglichst stark werden unser ziel
ist zweistellig zu werden möglichst nah
und bündnis 90/die grünen herankommen
weil wir dann eben einfluss haben auf
die koalitions formate und die inhalte
ich sage ganz offen weil cdu und csu
ihre innere mitte ja offensichtlich
nicht gefunden haben traue ich ihnen
nicht zu anliegen der grünen zu
begrenzen und auf der anderen seite hat
armin laschet ja bereits hingewiesen
auch herrn kiener auch herr trittin
taucht wieder öffentlich auftreten
schaltet sich in die debatten ein da
sieht man dass herr scholz gehören auch
mal richtig dass herr scholz ein
bürgerliches auftreten hat die anderen
sind aber noch begrenzt und deshalb
deshalb erfolgen durch sagen wäre wäre
die fdp tritt ein in einer koalition der
mitte grüne schulden rote
steuererhöhungen leicht was sie bei uns
nicht schnelle schlussfrage an alle und
bitte mit der betonung schnell welche
regierung soll uns regieren welche
koalition vor weiter natürlich eine mit
fdp-beteiligung
die inhaltlichen schnittmengen sind bei
jamaika am größten
union an nummer eins soll führen und
jamaika wäre eine option aber für uns
kommt es einfach hin zunächst mal daran
dass die bürgerliche regierung von uns
und von menschen geführt wird ja schon
alles für eine cdu csu geführte
regierung in welches koalition ja eins
ist jedenfalls bei uns klipp und klar
weder die linke noch die afg
eine klima regierung
können sie etwas präziser
hier gibt es nur mit starken grünen das
hat diese runde jahr deutlich gezeigt
sie bis zehn jahre weiter
kohleverstromung wird deutschland nicht
in klimaneutralität und damit auch nicht
in wohlstand der zukunft führen und
gefährdet die freiheit unserer kinder
und enkelkinder und welche das will ich
verhindern deswegen braucht eine grün
geführte regierung die endlich ein neues
kapitel aufschlägt für den wohlstand in
unserem land klimaneutral nochmal
konstellation welche koalition das
werden wir am ende sehen ob es für ein
zweierbündnis reicht für ein
dreierbündnis reicht aber ohne grüne an
der führung ist das wie klimaschutz das
klappt mich also keine antwort auf der
stelle herr scholz ganz aufgeschlagen
werden ich möchte die bürgerinnen bürger
bitten dass sie ihre entscheidung die
sie erwogen haben den letzten tagen und
wochen dass sie eine regierung wollen
die von mir geführt werden könnte auch
möglich machen indem sie ein starkes
votum für die spd abgeben die
zweitstimme ist die kanzler stimme will
dass sich der nächste regierungschef
werde der sollte auch die spd wählen wir
werden dann die möglichkeit nutzen
vielleicht reicht es ja auch zu zweit
das ist ja auch eine möglichkeit die
passieren kann und deshalb geht es vor
allem um ein sehr starkes votum weil
zurzeit haben sie nur eine dame
angeschaut frau wisse ja bei uns ist
ganz klar herr lasche wir werden sie
nicht zum kanzler wählen und herr
lindner wenig zu sagen finanzminister
programmatisch haben wir die größten
übereinstimmungen mit spd und grünen das
ist klar und da muss man eben nach der
wahl schauen wenn ich mir die
wahlkampagne so anschaue sehe ich da
viele übereinstimmungen muss man nach
der wahl schauen ob es leben reichen
politiker ich sage danke denn das war es
schon wieder mit unserer schlussrunde
die geht zu ende in drei tagen wissen
wir dann mehr zumindest wer und in
welcher konstellation eine chance hat
seine heute geäußerten vorstellungen
auch umsetzen zu können in der nachfolge
von angel merkel nach 16 jahren beginnt
dann nämlich eine neue ära und manchmal
wenn eine lange ära endet dauert es
länger als gedacht bis des neuen allen
konturen zu erkennen ist ihnen noch
einen guten und entspannten abend
ja soweit also die schlussrunde drei
tage vor der bundestagswahl live aus
berlin und damit herzlich willkommen
hier zurück bei zdf heute live ich bin
gespannt auf ihre fragen und kommentare
und vor allem bin ich gespannt darauf
wie unsere beiden experten des heutigen
abends die sendung gesehen haben und
dazu hole ich wieder mit zurück ins boot
hier in unsere sendung professor
thorsten faas politikwissenschaftler an
der fau berlin und den kollegen jan
schepmann von funk bekannt unter anderem
von politik format die da oben erfahren
was ist ihr eindruck wie haben sie die
letzten minuten gesehen
ja da war eine menge dynamik drin manche
würden sogar wahrscheinlich sagen da war
eine menge gift auch und häme durchaus
drin jeder und jeder hat versucht zu
wort zu kommen das ist bei sieben
teilnehmenden nicht ganz einfach noch
dazu wissen die alle wie sie sich das
wort holen wie sie sich auch sozusagen
dann für sich behalten also das war
schon sehr sehr komplex da war manches
spannende drin aber ich glaube so eine
richtige breitenwirkung die wird es
nicht unbedingt haben ich fürchte dafür
waren manche debatten dann doch zu sehr
im detail verstrickt und nicht ganz
leicht nachzuvollziehen
der kollegin niggemeier hat
zwischendurch getwittert warum muss das
sinngemäß so bissig sein so freudlos
dieses format hat ihm überhaupt nicht
gefallen er hatte offenbar eher ein
abschalt impuls als das sei irgendwie
neues interesse für politik noch mal
geweckt worden wäre aus seiner sicht wie
hast du das wahrgenommen
zum einen konnte ich tatsächlich als
zuschauer auch nicht so wirklich die
ganz klare struktur erkennen von von der
einen schnell fragerunde die keine waren
die nächste und da war auch nur bedingt
von den teilnehmern und teilnehmerinnen
den regeln zu folgen
es haben viele protagonisten da gerade
auf mich sehr müde gewirkt an erster
stelle armin laschet
und ja helme war definitiv dabei deshalb
ich glaube die haben alle auch so
langsam keine lust mehr auf diesen
wahlkampf gab es denn an der stelle wo
du gesagt hättest ok da hat jetzt jemand
aber und bock geschossen oder da hat
jemand wirklich richtig gepunktet
nochmal
der stärksten momente sendung war für
mich als olaf scholz bei der
persönlichen fast verzichtes frage aus
der reihe gestiegen ist und gesagt hat
ich muss hier ganz ehrlich sagen sagen
als politiker in gepanzerten autos mit
flugzeugen sind wir nicht die die den
anschein erwecken jetzt hier die große
vorbildfunktion ausüben das fand ich
tatsächlich sehr stark und
stolz hat außerdem bei bei seiner
einschätzung der nato seine seine
finanzminister stellung sehr gut
ausspielen können ansonsten wirklich
einen bock geschossen habe ich nicht
gesehen
große große siegeszug aber auch nicht
professor fast haben sie auch den
eindruck gehabt dass es bei den drei
kanzler kandidierenden er so ein
zurücklehnen war und er die anderen die
bühne für sich genutzt haben weil sie
jetzt auch mal die chance hatten oder
wie hat das auf sie gewirkt
die rede teil rede anteile war natürlich
ganz anders verteilt und insofern gab es
auch einen deutlichen unterschied zu den
tri allen die wir erlebt haben aber ich
bin gar nicht sicher annalena baerbock
hatte diesen moment wo sie dann auf
nachfrage doch sich zu enteignungen
bekannt hat und da merkte man sofort in
welcher phase des wahlkampfs wir
eigentlich sind weil da sind sofort alle
drauf gegangen achja enteignung
interessant dafür stehen sie also sie
hat dann auch sofort gemerkt das ist
jetzt ein kleiner heikler moment für sie
hat dann noch mal versucht es zu
relativieren aber ich fand das war so
ein moment wo man wie unter einem
brennglas eigentlich wahlkampfslogan
erkennen kann das war so eine
formulierung wo sie vielleicht so einen
ganz kleinen moment nicht aufgepasst hat
sich ein bisschen zu weit aus dem
fenster gelehnt hat allen anderen war
sofort klar dann setzt das ist doch so
für ein paar minuten den fokus da war
sie so bis eine defensive also insofern
das fand ich ein sehr bemerkenswerter
moment wo man einfach auch den wahlkampf
insgesamt deutlich wie in so einem
kristallisationspunkt ganz gut erkennen
konnte dann schauen wir uns den moment
noch mal genau an dem ich gerade das
thema enteignungen und gerade das was
sie angesprochen haben darüber würden
wir gerne noch ein bisschen
ausführlicher sprechen ich hoffe dass
liegt vor der ausschnitt und dann können
wir gemeinsam noch mal reinschauen
es steht klar im grundgesetz was aufgabe
von staatlichkeit ist und es auch im
grund gerecht mittel auch sie jetzt auch
starts richtung steht doch nicht drin
man somit
das ein letztes mittel auch am start zur
verfügung steht aber wir haben klar
gemacht als grüne in berlin und auch im
bund wir müssen alle schritte da
fortgehen dh die löcher in der mietpreis
bremse die müssen jetzt endlich
geschlossen werden das bedeutet endlich
die mittel für sozialen wohnungsbau
weiter zu erhöhen oder gruppen haben
sich das letzte was zu haben ist klar
ein eigenes models von berlin bis vor
dem verfassungsgericht scheitern wird
alle vorschnell das ist eigentlich nach
erhaltung anders als bei ihm ich
verstehe die aufregung auf der anderen
seite gar nicht beim thema enteignungen
also ist eine schwarz-gelbe
landesregierung nordrhein westfalen
gewesen wie zum beispiel für den
kohleabbau überhaupt kein problem hatte
zu enteignen oder vor autobahnprojekt
oder enteignen sie doch auch und das
grundgesetz lässt das doch möglich also
lässt es doch zu dass im interesse des
gemeinwohls auch enteignungen
stattfinden wir reden jetzt hat man das
nächste thema wo wir wahrscheinlich
ebenso in gemeinden dürfen nämlich
wir machen nicht alle also das können
wir auch nochmal würde dass sie es
fragen im viele spielregeln wir werden
nicht alle immer zu allen fragen zu wort
kommen lassen aber musste wo es ist
ausgewogen
tja da hat sogar noch einer reingerufen
ich weiß nicht genau wer es war konnte
die stimme nicht erkennen ist sie jetzt
auch noch
verfassungsrechtler rinn was natürlich
eine fiese sind sie auch noch mal herr
lindner er anhat hat differiert was auch
noch mal eine fiese spitze zum thema
lebenslauf von annalena baerbock
ist er wie hast du das wahrgenommen an
diesen moment
konstant kamen sticheleien ehrlich
gesagt in die richtung also herr lindner
auch mit seinem gott oh gott oh gott
also das ging primär auf die grünen aber
auch von herrn söder kam immer wieder
kleinere sticheleien in die ecke und ist
interessant zu sehen bei der enteignungs
nummer kamen frau wissler frau werbung
zu hilfe und hat gesagt ja hier die die
schwarz gelbe landesregierung in nrw die
hat beim autobahnbau aber auch beim
kohleabbau enteignet und da hat man
schon so ein bisschen fronten gesehen
dann schauen wir uns mal die aktuellen
zahlen an die uns direkt jetzt ganz
aktuell vom politbarometer vorliegen
denn da wurde noch mal ganz aktuell
jetzt zum letzten mal vor der
bundestagswahl gefragt wenn heute schon
bundestagswahl wäre dann kämen da
folgende zahlen raus hier ist die grafik
eine projektion wohlgemerkt keine
prognose eine projektion und da sehen
wir die cdu/csu also die union bei 23
prozent das ist ein prozentpunkt mehr
als vor einer woche das heißt die union
holt bisschen auf spd 25 afd 10 fdp elf
linke 6 grüne 16,5 die freien wähler 3
prozent und die anderen bei 5,5 prozent
das heißt wenn wir uns hier mal raus
greifen cdu und spd da wird wirklich ein
enges höschen die cdu holt auf den
letzten metern noch ein bisschen auf und
wenn wir schauen wie die frage ausfällt
wen hätten sie am liebsten als
bundeskanzler oder bundeskanzlerin 20
prozent für armin laschet 47 prozent für
olaf scholz
und 46 prozent für annalena baerbock 17
prozent sagen ich weiß das nicht und
dann haben die kollegen noch gefragt wer
denn als bundeskanzler oder
bundeskanzlerin am ehesten geeignet wäre
da sehen wir 26 prozent sagen nur jahr
für armin laschet 64 prozent sagen olaf
scholz ist geeignet und 25 prozent sagen
annalena baerbock ist geeignet das heißt
sowohl bei der frage nach der
beliebtheit als auch bei der eignung
liegt olaf scholz vorne gefolgt von
armin laschet und annalena baerbock auf
platz drei
soweit ich weiß genau gibt es noch eine
vierte grafik nämlich die der nach der
wahlentscheidung 65 prozent sagen ja
meine wahlentscheidung ist sicher 35
sagen nein ich bin mir noch nicht sicher
das war letzte woche 38 prozent das
heißt die zahl der entschieden ist ein
bisschen größer geworden die zahl der
unentschiedenen ein bisschen seiner im
vergleich zur vorwoche aber es sind ja
in der tat auch nur noch drei tage herr
professor farce wenn man sich anschaut
dass es dann doch noch ein paar
unentschlossene sind wie ausschlaggebend
war diese runde heute abend aus ihrer
sicht
ich fürchte ehrlich gesagt auf die
unentschlossenen nicht in allzu großer
zahl heute abend dabei gewesen sind weil
wir einfach wissen und das ist eine der
interessanten facetten von demokratie
diejenigen auf die es am ende ankommt
die unentschlossenen das sind nicht
immer die die jedes detail von politik
begleiten sondern das sind oft menschen
die so ein mäßiges interesse an politik
haben das ist vollkommen okay aber die
spannende frage ist dann genau wie
erreiche ich eigentlich diese leute auf
der zielgeraden was kann ich denen noch
mal wie kann ich die erreichen was kann
ich den noch mal mit geben und das
können ganz ganz verschiedene dinge sein
das kann etwas aus einem privaten umfeld
sein das kann sowas sein wien-wahl oma
hat aber das ist tatsächlich ganz schwer
vorherzusagen oder vorauszusagen was
diese menschen am ende zu einer
wahlentscheidung treibt und man muss
dazu sagen diese unsicherheit mündet mit
unter auch in nicht wahr insofern ist
auch die frage der mobilisierung wem
gelingt ist am ende auch menschen
tatsächlich zu wählerinnen und wählern
zu machen eine die noch mal ein
ausschlag gibt aber in der tat das ist
knapp das sind zwei prozentpunkte das
ist ungefähr das bild was wir so in den
letzten wochen und anderen umfragen auch
gesehen haben aber trotzdem das ist
nichts was jetzt absolut in stein
gemeißelt ist insofern es bleibt
spannend
jan es gibt eine userin die quasi noch
gerne überzeugt werden möchte quasi
stellvertretend für alle jungen
wählerinnen und wähler julia müller
fragt speziell an dich die frage viele
junge menschen haben ein gutes
bildungsniveau und arbeiten hart dennoch
ist es sehr schwer aus eigener kraft
vermögen anzusparen ist das wohlstands
versprechen der sozialen marktwirtschaft
gescheitert warum macht es die politik
jungen menschen so schwer
ich glaube da könnte man jetzt eine
eigene sendung darüber machen ich glaube
dass die parteien da sehr
unterschiedliche ansätze haben um junge
menschen die angebote zu machen wir
haben bei uns auf dem kanal gecheckt
welche wahlprogramme junge menschen
spezifisch also wie junge menschen haben
wir mit unter 30 eingegrenzt
ansprechen und da kann ich zumindest
sagen dass die programme von grünen und
fdp relativ klar auf junge menschen auch
zugegangen sind mehr als die anderen
das betrifft jetzt bereiche die exklusiv
auf junge menschen gehen wie
beispielsweise bafög
ausbildungsförderung aber auch
klimapolitik und es sind aber
unterschiedlich
angebot wieder gemacht werden das heißt
welche stellschrauben ein persönlich am
wichtigsten sind muss man je nach der
persönlichen lebenssituation glaube ich
sehen
sie aber tatsächlich dass sich diese
dieser einschätzung von uns mit mit fdp
und grünen sehr auch mit der
mit den zahlen bei jungen menschen
entdeckt wobei beide parteien sehr sehr
starke sprüche haben ich möchte einen
kurzen ausflug machen in richtung afd
die zweite war heute abend dabei
fasst es gibt fragen auch in richtung
afd zum beispiel fragt ein user namens
rumäne das ausschließen da fd ist ein
undemokratischer akt
und es gibt die frage von harald walter
per e-mail wenn ich das richtig sehe
ich frage mich ob es klug ist von cdu
csu und fdp eine koalition mit der afg
auszuschließen spd und grüne haben den
fehler lange mit der linkspartei gemacht
und das ergebnis waren große koalitionen
und zunehmende politikverdrossenheit das
ist ja in der tat was was aufgefallen
ist nicht nur heute abend sondern im
wahlkampf generell in richtung afd sind
alle anderen parteien ganz ganz klar
ja absolut dass es in der tat eine der
wenigen konstanten die wir rundum
zusammenarbeit von parteien sehen
jegliche form der zusammenarbeit der
koalition wird ausgeschlossen das ist
durchaus eine herausforderung für union
und auch die fdp weil sie durchaus an
verschiedenen stellen um ähnliche
wählerklientel kämpfen und ringen aber
gleichwohl geht es eben nicht nur darum
stimmen zu gewinnen sondern man hat es
ja auch heute abend gemerkt das ist
schon eine konfliktlinie die an vielen
stellen anders ist als das was wir sonst
als streit auseinandersetzungen der
politik haben da geht es um sehr sehr
grundsätzliche sachen da geht's auch
eben um das verhältnis zur demokratie
insofern kann das zumindest derzeit kein
verhältnis wie jedes andere sein die
union hat herausforderer auch
innerparteilich keine frage aber
trotzdem ist sie mit blick auf ihr
verhältnis zu afd wirklich sehr klar und
da bleibt sich auch kurzfristig nichts
dran ändern das mag man kritisieren wenn
man sagt das ist doch eine demokratisch
gewählte partei ja aber trotzdem wenn
man positionen sie die eben bestimmte
spielregeln der demokratie in frage
stellt dann ist das einfach kein
normales verhältnis was man da zu dieser
partei pflegen würde
dann schauen wir auf ein anderes
verhältnis nämlich zwischen zwei männern
die heute abend nebeneinander gesessen
haben wir haben vorhin schon drüber
gesprochen
söder laschet nebeneinander in derselben
sendung der eine der kandidat und der
andere der kandidat der herzen so als du
das vorhin genannt ja wir gucken uns mal
einen kleinen ausschnitt aus diesem
duell kann man es nicht nennen bereden
wir gleich darüber bestand an
das führt am ende zum gleichen wie bei
gerhard schröder
also ich hab mir jetzt ein bild sofort
mit dürfen deswegen will dies nur
ergänzen habe viele gute trelle schon
was da passiert genau das gleiche es
geht genau los wie bei lafontaine und
schröder viele viele ideen viele viele
experimente am ende stand das land kurz
vor dem ruin das darf nicht passieren
tja was war das so ein freudscher
kleiner moment wo man gemerkt hat okay
söder hat jetzt die chance zu reden und
jetzt muss er auch reden und bedauert es
quasi dass er im entry allen die ja
angesprochen habe selber dann doch nicht
selbst anwesend war
ja es fällt ihnen dann doch sichtbar
schwer einfach im zweiten glied zu
stehen es gab ein paar andere passagen
wo er armin laschet so etwas
da lassen sich die beiden herren alleine
da ist
vielleicht können sie vielleicht können
sie einfach noch mal ansetzen genau die
beiden herren man merkt einfach dass es
nichts ist was ihm leicht fällt ins
zweite glied zu rücken mal eben mit dem
anderen armin laschet an der stelle die
bühne zu lassen insgesamt hat man glaube
ich die chance die die beiden gehabt
hätten sich da auch ein paar bälle
zuzuspielen nicht wirklich genutzt
insofern merkt man schon noch eine
gemeinsame wahlkampfstrategie die konnte
man selbst heute abend nicht unbedingt
erkennen aber spitzen zumindest gab es
von markus söder auch nicht das wäre bei
dieser bühne und diesem format heute
wirklich auch nachfragen gewesen und wir
wissen beide versuchen sich vegetarisch
zu ernähren das fand ich dann doch auch
ganz bemerkenswert ja da waren sie sich
sehr einig dass weniger fleisch auch gut
tut
jan
weil herr fast gerade sagte für heute
abend war das nicht zu erwarten aber am
sonntagabend sitzen ja ulkiger weise
quasi dieselben menschen im selben
setting zusammen nur dann heißt es
berliner runde und dann ist es eben
nicht vor der wahl sondern nach der wahl
und auch dann werden mutmaßlich wieder
söder und laschet in dieser runde
zusammensitzen glaubst du dass dann der
moment sein wird wo markus söder sagen
wird
jetzt wäre ein guter zeitpunkt für den
rückzug
es kommt auch das wahlergebnis an also
wenn laschet wirklich das historisch
schlechte cdu gibt es oder unions
ergebnis einfährt dann kann ich mir
schon vorstellen dass söder da
insbesondere mit blick auf potenzielle
koalitionsverhandlungen so ein bisschen
dass das macht handtuch an sich zieht
ich würde gern noch ergänzen grad ich
habe zwar keiner über den spitzen heute
gesehen aber in mehreren fällen hat man
gemerkt dass sie immer noch das letzte
wort haben wollte wenn da schon etwas
gesagt hat selbst bei der bei der
fleisch frage hat er gesagt ja einfach
mal ein bisschen weniger bisschen
weniger hinterher noch geschoben und das
war nicht das einzige mal wo er dann
doch mal gegners drauf gesetzt hat als
armin laschet und was gesagt hatte und
die gemeinsamkeit der beiden gesehen
habe ist halt einfach die die front
gegen links so das ist auch das was die
unionsparteien online zu durchziehen und
auch seit wochen in triengen jetzt von
einem dach statt immer wiedergekommen
ist diese die spd oder die grünen oder
die linke die gibt es nicht einzeln mehr
wie ist es immer nur noch geht der
linksrutsch oder der rot rot grün das
ist und das ist schon super und lasche
gleichermaßen so betont worden heute
also da gab es zumindest eine gewisse
einigkeit
ganz viele fragen gibt es hier im chat
dazu warum markus söder überhaupt da war
also warum die union nicht nur durch
armin laschet vertreten wird sondern
eben durch beide parteivorsitzenden
thomas soko fragt zum beispiel über
facebook warum sind da cdu und csu
anwesend beide parteien treten
bundesweit als eine partei auf die csu
in bayern die cdu im restlichen
bundesgebiet
und sascha pötting schreibt auch über
youtube unfair dass cdu/csu im doppelt
so viele mediale aufmerksamkeit bekommen
die anderen parteien sollten sich auch
in jedem bundesland einzeln aufstellen
und dann mit 16 vorsitzenden antreten
ich glaube wenn man sich die kämpfe
zwischen der union anguckt dann nichts
was wirklich empfehlenswert wäre für
alle anderen aber
wir schauen ganz schnell auf die seite
des bundeswahlleiters der eine antwort
auf diese frage gibt bei cdu und csu
handelt sich um zwei unterschiedliche
parteien mit eigenen wahlvorschlägen und
da es eben sich um zwei unterschiedliche
parteien handelt muss jede partei für
sich mindestens fünf prozent der im
wahlgebiet das heißt bundesweit
abgegebenen gültigen zweitstimmen
erhalten oder in mindestens drei
wahlkreisen ein mandat errungen haben
und wenn man jetzt die bisherigen
stimmen der csu umrechnet auf die fünf
prozent auf bundesebene je nach
wahlbeteiligung und gesamtzahl der
gültigen stimmen dann sind es bei 31 bis
32 prozent im freistaat eben mehr als 5
prozent im bund herr fast das ist eine
sehr komplizierte regelung lief aber
quasi lebensnotwendig für die csu ist
grundlage für die teilnahme auch an
diesen runden und steht aber jetzt ein
bisschen auf der kippe denn die csu
steht auch was die umfragen vor der
jetzigen bundestagswahl angeht in bayern
nicht besonders gut da
man absolut und deswegen noch mal mit
blick auf die berliner runde von sonntag
kann man erst mal sagen da werden wir
einander markus söder erleben denn man
muss sehen markus söder haftet auch
durchaus der makel an nicht wirklich
bisher richtig tolle wahlergebnisse für
die csu geholt zu haben das wird er auch
am sonntag nicht tun aber insofern wird
er alles tun klarzustellen dass das mit
ihm relativ wenig zu tun hat sondern mit
armin laschet das vielleicht nochmals
fußnote dazu in der tat ich meine man
muss sich in die situation von
wählerinnen und wählern versetzen der
anspruch dieser sendung ist ja
grundsätzlich dass jeder das angebot was
ihm oder ihr am sonntag auf dem
wahlzettel präsentiert wird heute abend
noch mal kennenzulernen und insofern ist
das argument letztlich aus formaler sich
naja wenn heute zuschauern zuschauer aus
bayern zugeschaut haben die können nicht
die cdu von armin laschet wählen die
können nur die csu von markus söder
wählen das ist das argument warum die
parteien und es sind zweifel parteien
csu ist kein landesverband der union
sondern ist eine eigene partei warum sie
da vertreten sind aber trotzdem es gibt
den ganz natürlich so einen leicht touch
des unfairen wenn man so will denn in
der tat man könnte ja sagen die spd
teilt sich auch in einen nord und einen
süd spd und dann ist sie da auch
plötzlich doppelt vertreten das ist eben
ein kuriosum was wir in deutschland
haben aber was beim sie haben der
bundeswahlleiter zitiert wahl rechtmäßig
und einen blick auf die wahl sind es
zwei parteien diese
fraktionsgemeinschaft die sich danach im
deutschen bundestag bildet das ist
tatsächlich etwas was danach passiert
könnte sagen es gibt den gemeinsamen
spitzenkandidaten das gibt es gemeinsame
wahlprogramm aber das ist alles nichts
was juristisch fixiert ist da sind es
zwei parteien daran halten sich ja der
und zdf um deswegen sind sie doppelt
vertreten
soweit ich weiß ist das ein thema das
euch auch in der redaktion immer wieder
begegnet und wo ihr auch immer wieder
versuchen bis antworten darauf zu finden
ja und vor allen dingen ich geh mal so
ein paar jahre zurück die in famoser
elefantenrunde von 2005 als gerhard
schröder
paar gute manieren vergessen hat sich
jetzt sagen aber da ging es ja genau
darum er hat gesagt ich bin der der
kandidat der partei die am meisten
stimmen geholt hat und wenn man die hat
also csu und die cdu als einzelne
parteien sieht da hat es auch gestimmt
da hat die er mehr stimmten damals
geholt als angela merkel die ergebnisse
von cdu und csu werden da halt addiert
und das ist halt am ende dann
da würde ich mich anschließen das ist
das touch unfaire was da am ende darüber
kommt und ja manchmal entscheidet so was
dann im endeffekt auch über die die die
besetzung ins kanzleramt das viessmann
2005 gesehen hatte hat schröders halt
nichts gebracht am ende wenn man bei der
union bleibt die an und auf dem die den
blick nach die nach der wahl richtet hat
gerade gesagt wir werden einen anderen
markus söder erleben nun wissen wir
nicht was passiert aber
womit rechnest du auch im hinblick
darauf wie sich die union entwickeln
wird nach diesem wahlabend
ich glaube da hängt ganz ganz ganz viel
dran für die union insbesondere die cdu
wenn armin laschet jetzt wirklich so ein
mieses ergebnis einfährt dann ist das
eine kettenreaktion dann kann er nicht
vorsitzender der cdu bleiben dann kann
er auch nicht nächstes jahr in nrw als
ministerpräsident antreten da
wiedergewählt zu werden dann ist das
stück ein kartenhaus zusammenbricht und
man hat ja jetzt auch schon gesehen im
wahlkampf sehe ich die cdu und auch die
csu oft inhaltlich relativ blank da
hatten und sich viel darüber definiert
wer man nicht ist und was man nicht will
und
das zieht sich durch ganz ganz viele
strukturen der cdu besonders dass da
inhaltlich sehr viel hat einfach ein
status quo erwartet wurde über viele
viele jahre hinweg weil man es nicht
anders musste mit frau merkel an
vorderster front gehört einfach auch
vieles abgehalten hat eine von der
partei und wenn am landschaft das ding
noch zu gewinnen dann hat sie die cdu
insbesondere aber auch die csu die
chance
ein bisschen intern zu renovieren und
sich auch neu aufzustellen aber wenn
jetzt wirklich so eine katastrophe
passiert dann könnte da ganz ganz viele
sich zusammenbrechen pablo diablo
schreibt dazu über youtube die cdu muss
wieder in die opposition und um ein
eigenes programm wieder aufstellen zu
können momentan ist und wird es eine
wiederholung das ist die meinung dieses
users herr professor fast die frage ist
ja entscheidend platz 1 oder platz zwei
für union und spd und wir haben auch
heute abend erlebt dass keiner sich hat
aus der reserve locken lassen was dann
passieren würde wenn er denn doch auf
der zwei wäre und damit sind wir bei der
frage nach den koalitionen welche
szenarien halten sie denn da im moment
für wahrscheinlich also es kann ja frau
hassel hat es versucht keiner hat
geantwortet es kann ja nicht plötzlich
am montagmorgen jeder mit jedem
plötzlich telefonieren irgendwie muss
ich die prioritäten geben heute abend
schlauer geworden
nein nicht wirklich und so ganz unrecht
hat sie tatsächlich nicht an der stelle
denn wir haben für so eine situation
nicht wirklich vorher erfahrung wir
haben eine dermaßen komplexe situation
wir dachten ja schon 2017 ist ein
komplex mit jamaika und es klappt dann
nicht und dann groko aber das war ja im
vergleich noch ein wahnsinnig
strukturierter prozess ich glaube die
entscheidende frage wird sein wie groß
der abstand zwischen den ersten beiden
parteien sein wird wenn der groß sein
wird und wenn insbesondere dann
vielleicht auch christian lindner sagen
wird gehen wir mal davon aus die spd
bleibt vorne er sieht jetzt keine
perspektive für jamaika das kriegt man
kommunikativ nicht vermittelt dann wird
es in der tat sehr sehr eng für armin
laschet dann bin ich ganz bei dem was
wir schon gehört haben das ist
eigentlich für armin laschet und seine
politische karriere dann das ende sein
dürfte wenn der abstand schmal ist es
gibt keine regel dass die stärkste
fraktion die stärkste partei einen
irgendwie gearteten anspruch auf den
kanzler zumindest nicht rechtlich
juristisch gleich politische aber nicht
rechtlich juristisch insofern wird man
alles versuchen auch aus sicht von armin
laschet persönlich da irgendwie im spiel
zu bleiben die cdu die union auch zu
disziplinieren damit aber nochmal wir
wissen noch nicht mal ob man da erst
paarweise sprechen wird ob man gleich in
möglichen koalitionskonstellationen
sprechen es wird hoch spannend sein zu
sehen wie sich das entwickelt wirkliche
vorlagen haben wir dafür tatsächlich
kein wir haben nur gelernt dass es beim
letzten mal sehr sehr lange gedauert hat
es immer mal gespannt wie wie schnell
ist diesmal geht's ja das ist die cd
sind die csu der cdu möglichkeiten oder
die unions möglichkeiten die spd hat es
natürlich auch nicht leicht wenn man
sich anguckt was spd-parteivize kevin
kühnert heute in der rheinischen post
gesagt hat dass hat armin laschet
weidlich ausgekostet vorhin in der runde
er hat noch einmal auf den
mitgliederentscheid hingewiesen den
kevin kühnert in aussicht gestellt hat
er hat zitiert das kühnert christian
lindner einen luftikus genannt hat also
damit die verlässlichkeit der fdp noch
mal infrage gestellt hat was die
koalitionsoptionen der spd angeht hat
kevin kühnert heute sein partei da einen
gefallen getan
ich meine ich weiß nicht warum herr
laschet also ein kühler fetisch hat das
ist einer von von ich glaube sechs
vize-chefs der erde der spd und da hat
er ja irgendwie so an frauchen und
herrchen hat so wissen so narren
gefressen
es ist aber auch kevin kindern vergeht
kein geheimnis daraus gemacht dass er
auch wenn es darum gehen würde am
liebsten einfach wirklich und eine
rot-grüne regierung hätte die ist
unwahrscheinlich aber er hätte auch
lieber ein rot grün rotes bündnis als
eine ampel das hat er auch nie ein hehl
draus gemacht das sehen andere in der in
der spd ganz anders ich würde ganz gerne
noch mal kurz über den händen
versprechen der hat ja heute noch mal
gesagt mit an sicherheit grenzender
wahrscheinlichkeit herr werden 70
prozent der bürger und bürgerinnen den
erstplatzierten nicht gewählt haben im
sommerinterview hat er noch gesagt mit
einem sicherheit grenzender
wahrscheinlichkeit wird der auftrag zur
bildung einer regierung an herrn laschet
gehen und damit es da auch noch mal
seine präferenz betont auf einmal in die
andere richtung um geschwungen und dass
er am liebsten mit mit herrn laschet wie
auch in nrw gemeinsame sache machen
würde das ist
ja das ist kein geheimnis was für mich
am ende wirklich für diese
sondierung aber oder auch kohl
koalitionsverhandlungen am ende den
ausschlag geben wird ist ob rechnerisch
eine rot grün rote mehrheit und einer
ampel möglich sind weil wenn die eine
rot grün rote koalition möglich wäre
dann hätte die fdp ein deutlich ein
deutlich schlechteres
verhandlungsposition als wenn es nicht
möglich wäre wenn ein linksbündnis nicht
möglich wäre dann könnte sich die fdp
eine ampel ganz ganz ganz teuer erkaufen
lassen deswegen da wäre dann die fdp am
drücker entweder aus einer potenziellen
jamaika koalition oder auch sampl das
rauszuholen was sie am liebsten hätte
das viel oder frage ob die grünen das
mitmachen
wäre wäre wenn viele viele fragezeichen
das macht diese wahl so unglaublich
spannend zu den koalitionen noch einen
kommentar von die user matze der sagt
schon krass hinterher kommt dass mit den
koalitionen raus was keiner wollte das
haben wir doch schon das wissen wir
jetzt natürlich noch nicht das wissen
wir dann auch noch wahrscheinlich nicht
am sonntagabend sondern dann müssen wir
uns ein bisschen gedulden
der wahlforscher weiß wind und regen
haben einfluss auf das wahlverhalten
jungen leute gehen bei sonne bier
trinken senioren bleiben bei regen er zu
hause dieses jahr wurde viel briefwahl
gemacht was erwarten sie dafür den für
den sonntag
die briefwahl sollte erst mal dazu
führen dass vielleicht der einfluss des
wetters dieses mal überschaubar bleibt
wobei diese wettert hießen auch immer
sehr gern zitiert werden aber sie haben
ja auch schon angedeutet es darf nicht
zu sonnig sein es darf aber auch nicht
regnen irgendwie muss es so ein
trockener aber doch eher unangenehmer
tag sein dass viele menschen gehen die
wissenschaft sagte eigentlich so klar
sind die zusammenhänge nicht aber
insgesamt ist es einfach und das hat
finde ich der heutige abend auch noch
mal sehr schön gezeigt insofern einfach
nur offene frage weil ich glaube viele
menschen gerade auch mit der frage ring
was will ich eigentlich am sonntag
entscheiden will ich den nächsten
kanzler mit prägen will ich vielleicht
ein bestimmtes thema wählen klima wenn
man noch mal den klimastreit morgen als
auch da gibt es nochmal thematischen
akzent will ich doch die ära merkel
irgendwie fortsetzen weil es vielleicht
insgesamt keine schlechten jahre waren
und insofern geht es jetzt gar nicht
mehr darum bestimmte themen ganz neu zu
überdenken sondern sich eigentlich klar
zu werden zu der frage was will ich was
definiert eigentlich diese wahl und das
ist schon faszinierend dass drei tage
vor der wahl für viele menschen noch
wirklich so grundsätzliche fragen im
raum stehen und wenn wir sehen dass bei
der union werden die politbarometer
zahlen ja eben gesehen da so eine ganz
leichte erholung erkennbar ist in der
person laschet kann das nicht liegen die
zahlen wir auch gesehen dann ist es
vielleicht doch noch mal so eine so eine
rückbesinnung naja eigentlich habe ich
die vielleicht doch immer gewählt
vielleicht mache ich dann dieses mal
doch aber es bleibt einfach aber
spannend und auch die wahlbeteiligung ob
wetterbedingt oder briefwahl bedingen
pandemie bedingt aber natürlich wird
auch die eine rolle spielen wem es
gelingt die meisten wählerinnen und
wähler zu mobilisieren ist eine binse
aber trotzdem richtig natürlich hat
deren vorteil gegenüber parteien die
einfach gerade mobilisierungsprobleme
haben
jan ein user weiß ganz genau was er will
armin weiß über facebook sagt ich will
mein auto weiterfahren anständigen lohn
haben keine kriege und glückliche kinder
und rentner sehen ein gesundes kranken
und rentensystem wer schafft das ich
erwarte nicht von dir dass du die frage
beantworten kannst aber natürlich es ist
das was im prinzip alle wollen und es
müssen alle parteien irgendwie leisten
indem sie eine tatkräftige neue
bundesregierung stellen
ja das würde in der tat alle so
unterschreiben glauben ich und selbst
den grünen den immer hinterher geredet
wird dass sie das autofahren verbieten
wollte sollen ja auch nicht das ist ja
auch quatsch erzählt friedrich merz auf
irgendwelchen wahlkampf bühnen aber das
ist halt nicht der fall all diese sachen
sind im ziel dass das gleich über den
parteien die wege dahin sind halt
fundamental unterschiedlich und auch die
verantwortung wo die liegen bei den
parteien fundamental unterschiedlich
bestes beispiel pflege wie viel wie viel
verantwortung hat er der einzelne für
seine seine zukunft und wie viel hat der
staat wer soll was für wen finanzieren
da sind hat die unterschiedlichen
konzepte der parteien zu sehen und die
wird dass das wird einem nicht durch
eine wahlsendung beantwortet da kann man
sich sehr sehr tief in sehr sehr lange
wahlprogramme ein lesen was die
wenigsten tun werden und ich befürchte
halt dass menschen die halt einfach
diese wünsche äußern
sehr sehr schwer auf alles eine antwort
bekommen werden
jan schildmann für
games sind total spannender punkt weil
der uns daran erinnert dass das menschen
eigentlich gerne ziele erfüllt sehen zu
sich und das land und eigentlich gerne
die partei wählen würden der sie das
einfach anvertrauen möchten da geht es
eben nicht immer um die allerletzten
details der maßnahmen wo es diese
unterschiede gibt sondern da geht es
eben auch so richtungsentscheidung wem
traue ich das zu wo habe ich ein gutes
gefühl und insofern auch wenn die frage
sehr sehr breit formuliert war in all
den wünschen aber dass das ich finde das
zeigt sehr schön die wählerinnen und
wähler an so ein wahlkampf rangehen und
das dann so manche debatte welches jahr
welcher prozentsatz welche maßnahmen
exakte geht manchmal genau an diesen
wünschen von wählerinnen wählern ein
tanzstück bad vorbei also nochmal die da
würde ich vielleicht tatsächlich gerne
ergänzen das sehr interessant weil es
gibt ja die umfragen was wäre gewesen
wenn markus söder kanzlerkandidat
gewesen wäre und da kann man natürlich
alles mal außen vor lassen was dann darf
vielleicht auch in die hose gegangen
wäre aber markus söders auftreten ist
für mich halt steht komplett im
gegensatz zu dem von amina
bestritt halt einfach befestigt auch wie
einer machte der der fels in der
brandung der die auch nach elf stunden
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz auch um
halb eins in der nacht in einer
pressekonferenz ohne ein stottern 1 nr
glasklar erklären kann was da gerade
überhaupt passiert ist was da
beschlossen wurde und gerade diese
gefälligkeit in einer person glaube ich
ist eine sache die sich sehr dass viele
menschen gewünscht hätten und das ist
für mich auch so ein so am besten dass
das große paradoxe ende dieses
wahlkampfes diese diese divergenz
zwischen der person söder und der der
person laschet die da am ende stehen
bleibt und diese große was wäre wenn und
dass ich glaube das ist ein wahnsinniger
unterschied gemacht wäre da die
entscheidung anders ausgefallen
da muss man natürlich unterscheiden
zwischen festigkeit der person im
inneren und im auftreten und was die
inhalte angeht haben wir ja auch gesehen
dass das markus söder da durchaus sehr
wankelmütig ist ein kann in der
vergangenheit aber erfasst also doch
kein mensch schnell
ich gebe das gerne noch mal an sie
weiter weil das gespräch zwischen ihnen
beiden auch gerade irgendwie ich möchte
das ungern unterbinden das ist ja nicht
nur eine frage die union hatte sondern
das hatten wir auch die grünen also auch
da gab es ja zwischen bernburg und habe
auch was die beliebtheit angeht und was
was in den umfragen die kompetenz und
das vertrauen anging hätten viele gesagt
lasst uns den haarweg nehmen da sind wir
auf der sicheren seite und am ende hat
sich die partei oder haben sich die
beiden untereinander für annalena
baerbock entschieden auch da ist
natürlich die frage hat man da auf den
richtigen kann die unter die richtige
kandidatin gesetzt
ja absolut alleine schon die tatsache
dass diese debatten geführt werden nimmt
den parteien natürlich ein stück weit
genau diese festigkeit von der jan
gerade gesprochen hat das eben nicht
klar als wer wofür steht die partei
eigentlich ist es habe ist dass bernburg
ist es so da ist dass laschet bei
beider kommt sicherlich hinzu keine
frage man hätte gegen sünder auch
hervorragend polarisieren können aber
die frage wer eben gewesen ob diese
vorwürfe verfangen hätten oder ob das
nicht einfach an ihm abperlt wäre merkel
hat immer diesen satz gesagt sie kennen
mich vertrauen sie mir ich mache das
schon das ist genau dieses gefühl wenn
es gelingt eine partei einer person das
zu vermitteln dann ist es pures gold in
seiner wahlkampf zeit weil das ganz
viele
vertrauensbildenden maßnahmen unnötig
macht weil das vertrauen einfach da ist
bei harbeck wäre ich ein bisschen
vorsichtiger auch robert habeck hat
einige fehler unklaren äußerungen in
interviews gemacht man weiß nie was
wirklich passiert wenn man in diesem
absoluten fokus steht das ist nicht das
gleiche ob ich co parteivorsitzender der
grünen bin oder ob ich der
kanzlerkandidat der grünen bin auch
harbeck wäre sicherlich noch mal ganz
anders gewogen worden in diesem
wahlkampf und insofern wäre ich da nicht
ganz so sicher söder in der tat der
würde seinen man glaube ich stehen und
an dem wäre manches abgeperlt was bei
laschet wirklich der union
kopfzerbrechen bereitet hat aber dieser
faktor vertrauen kompetenz ausstrahlen
das scheint in diesem wahlkampf
wirklichen großen unterschied zu machen
denn auch das trauen die menschen olaf
scholz beispielsweise zu den man ja auch
vieles vorgeworfen hatte in diesem
wahlkampf aber seine werte gerade eben
auch die kompetenzwerte wir sind
eigentlich durchweg hoch geblieben davon
profitiert er darf profitiert die spd
ja ich will jetzt nicht schon wieder den
fehler machen das versuchen diese
sendung zu werden wenn du da gerne noch
mal drauf aber wir haben möchte sehr
gerne wir haben hier no limits
ich kann mich tatsächlich anschließend
ich glaube dass die sache habe kreßberg
anders aus zu bewerten ist auch die
beliebtheitswerte der beiden waren ja
dann am ende als als aller berbalk so
kannst du kandidaten gekürt worden ist
fast gleichauf der hartberger über über
wochen monate immer mehr
aufgeholt auch während die
beliebtheitswerte von armin laschet
katastrophal waren als er zum
kanzlerkandidaten gemacht worden ist er
ist einer der unbeliebtesten
ministerpräsidenten ist das landes
gewesen ich gibt eine zweite
unbeliebteste zu dem zeitpunkt söder war
unter die top 3 der beliebtesten damals
und das war da schon nach einem jahr
pandemie also da da da hat man sehr sehr
lange erfahrungswerte gehabt wie diese
menschen wahrgenommen werden babelsberg
ist das ja hat ist auch keiner der immer
stabil aufgetreten ist er ist jemand der
glaube ich den satz dann doch meistens
noch mal zu kompliziert denkt im
vergleich zum vorjahr und ja es halt im
herzen immer noch philosoph so auch wenn
ich glaube dass er der ist der am
ehesten der kandidat gewesen wäre der
eine gewisse der guten kompromiss
angeboten hätte auch ein cdu wähler die
nach merkel sich bei der partei nicht
mehr so ganz wohl gefühlt haben das hat
er in schleswig holstein auf sehr sehr
gut gemacht
ich aber habe das ist eine ganz andere
sache dann würde ich an der stelle bevor
wir tatsächlich zu später stunde über
kandidaten sprechen diese am ende nicht
geworden sind im namen von liesel pumpe
über youtube sagen danke für die chat
live runde vielen dank an jan schepmann
vielen dank an professor fast für die
analyse noch so zu später stunde vielen
dank und viele userinnen und user haben
mitgemacht mit kommentiert und auch ganz
oft ihre partei präferenz in den chat
geschrieben was natürlich total spannend
ist aber wir leider hier in der sendung
so nicht weitergeben können aber es gab
auch sehr viele fragen danke dafür an
dieser stelle nochmal der hinweis
auf unseren faktencheck die zdf heute
hat natürlich alles was in der sendung
war geprüft und das hier ist unser
hinweis auf morgen greta thunberg wird
morgen bei uns bei zdf heute live in der
sendung sein großer klima streik morgen
noch einmal und natürlich nicht an einem
zu verlegen datum sondern so kurz vor
der bundestagswahl ein interessanter tag
und ein sehr interessanter gesprächsgast
darauf freuen wir uns fragen und
kommentare wie immer gerne auch auf den
bekannten wegen an uns und jetzt aber
erst mal gute nacht danke fürs dabei
sein